nous allons donc démarrer cette cette
deuxième journée de travaux dans le
cadre du projet de loi de financement
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale donc
pour 2023 ou dès le matin vous êtes déjà
bien dissipé mes chers collègues
alors depuis hier matin vous l'attendez
tous le nombre d'amendements examinés
nous en avons examiné sur la journée
d'hier
237 il ne nous reste donc plus que 5315
amendements
et je vous propose donc de poursuivre
nous n'avions pas terminé donc l'article
2 et je vais passer la parole à Monsieur
abiranier merci madame la Présidente
dans l'index seniors pour l'enrichir
tout simplement l'index Seigneur sur la
formation professionnelle des
travailleurs évidemment seniors
EUR
l'un des problèmes si on veut
augmenter le taux d'activité des seniors
ces problèmes de la formation beaucoup
d'entreprises
des investissent si je puis dire en
matière de formation sur les seniors et
donc l'idée de cet amendement c'est de
dire que dans les indicateurs doit y
avoir un indicateur relatif au taux
d'investissement de l'entreprise dans la
formation de ces salariés seniors
c'est ça l'idée
très bien Madame la rapportant merci
bonjour à toutes et tous on peut
s'accorder sur le fond de ces critères
par contre comme on l'a dit beaucoup
hier déjà il me semble que les critères
qui doivent être définies avec les
entreprises avec les organisations
syndicales et que la voix d'un décret
pris après ses concertations avec les
organisations syndicales me paraît la
meilleure option c'est pourquoi je reste
défavorable à ces amendements
très bien j'ai plusieurs demandes de
paroles déjà monsieur Maillard
oui merci madame la Présidente juste
peut-être moins sur l'amendement mais
sur la bonne tenue de notre séance
nous sommes je crois qu'on a on prend le
temps et tant mieux on voit bien vous
l'avez dit avec le nombre d'amendements
qu'on déjà été discuté et le nombre
d'amendements qui restent à discuter qui
serait bien au moins qu'on puisse
arriver sur l'article 7 et pour ça il
nous semblerait bien qu'on puisse
accélérer peut-être de faire le système
d'impôt un contre et puis au moment au
moment où il y a je termine vous direz
ce que vous pensez et au moment où il y
a des sujets peut-être vous voyez qu'il
y a besoin d'un peu plus de discussions
de tous les groupes qu'on puisse à ce
moment-là on a passé hier 4h ou 5 heures
sur une partie sur l'index senior qui
est un point important mais il y a
d'autres points très importants dans
cette réforme et qui me sort qui nous
semble en tout cas pour le groupe
Renaissance importante qu'on puisse
discuter en commission donc si on
pouvait faire un pour un contre
et qu'on soit pas dans des tunnels
d'amendement qui font que nous
n'avançons pas je vous remercie madame
la présence très bien monsieur
le monsieur Maillard
personnellement je souhaite
effectivement que nous puissions avancer
on a jusqu'à présent examiner deux
thématiques qui sont importantes soit
mais il y en a d'autres il y a d'autres
sujets aussi voilà
très important donc moi je suis pas
contre je l'avais déjà d'ailleurs
proposé hier de faire un pour un contre
voilà et il y a énormément d'amendements
les groupes de toute façon s'expriment
il y a beaucoup de redit de redondance
de paraphrases je pense qu'à un moment
donné tout le monde a bien imprimé que
il y avait des accords alors je passe la
parole à Monsieur Clouet
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
alors
si on est sur la question
si jamais on
si jamais non mais je sais que ça n'a
pas duré c'est le moment de
l'installation il y a pas de problème il
y a un sas d'arrivée alors sur la bonne
tenue des débats monsieur Maillard a
tout à fait raison mais je pense qu'on
est d'accord entre nous pour dire que
c'est pas qu'une question de forme mais
aussi de fond d'abord la structure du
texte bon on ne l'a pas choisi
d'ailleurs je vais je vais vous avouer
que si on avait dû l'écrire nous il y
aurait pas la même chose dedans il y a
même structure mais c'est pas grave et
en revanche il faut quand même bien voir
que nous on accorde beaucoup d'estime à
votre texte à son contenu et c'est bien
la raison pour laquelle on a envie d'en
discuter chaque ligne et chaque article
parce que il nous semble que il est très
intéressant il permet de poser des
questions qui sont fondamentales pour
l'avenir du pays et je trouve dommage de
qui failli l'opposition pour prendre au
sérieux un texte aussi important et
vouloir le discuter vraiment nous ce que
vous produisez ce que vous écrivez nous
intéresse énormément et je pense ça
intéresse vraiment le pays entier et
qu'il faut prendre le temps de le
discuter ce qui est ce qui est dommage
évidemment c'est que le temps est limité
mais là aussi c'est au-delà de nos
forces de pouvoir l'élargir alors sur
l'amendement puisqu'une intervention
évidemment se rapporte toujours un
amendement je venais en soutien à ceci
puisque cette question d'information
elle est fondamentale et c'est sans
doute ici le un des points aveugles du
texte qu'on discute on le sait l'accès à
la formation professionnelle il est
inégalité il est d'autant plus fréquent
que l'entreprise est grande taille et
que les salariés ont déjà des diplômes
et l'enjeu derrière est énorme c'est un
enjeu de qualification donc de
connaissances dans la vie quotidienne et
de capacité à transmettre ses
connaissances à ses proches c'est une
question de qualification donc de
salaire donc de conventions collective
bref ce qui se joue là c'est la capacité
des salariés à tout simplement disposer
d'un pouvoir d'agir qui me paraît plus
garanti par la reconnaissance des
qualifications que par je ne sais quel
index dont on ne comprend toujours pas
très bien qui est touché et quels seront
les conséquences effectives sur le monde
du travail
oui madame la Présidente moi je puisque
la question est posée sur le déroulé de
nos débats etc bon nous depuis hier on
essaye sincèrement d'alimenter des
choses qui étaient un peu creuses alors
qu'en face on a pas beaucoup de
répondant et moi je lis la presse ce
matin et j'apprends que hier au bureau
exécutif de Renaissance on a beaucoup
parlé de l'index senior et des pistes
d'assouplissement ou en tous les cas
d'enrichissement puisque je vois que
vous envisagez même en tous les cas
c'est la note de Sacha Houlier et de
Pascal Campin donc je me dis mais alors
c'est où est-ce que ça se décide parce
qu'il y a une commission des affaires
sociales qui est celle où on nous dit
bah il faut travailler les textes pour
permettre de faire de la coproduction de
pouvoir enrichir etc et nous découvrons
mais vous allez nous dire si c'est le
cas ou pas que vous envisagez de déposer
en séance dans l'hémicycle des choses
sur lesquelles vous avez objecté et voté
contre en commission des affaires
sociales c'est-à-dire les propositions
qui rendent l'index senior plus
coercitif nous les avons faites les
propositions qui abaissent le seuil à 50
pour
l'application nous les avons faites etc
donc il y a un moment donc je veux bien
que vous nous disiez et manifestement
c'est la preuve du dialogue fécond que
nous avons eu voilà parce que nous
sommes plusieurs à intervenir nos idées
ont infusé elles ont pu diffuser elles
ont pu être reprises par vous elles ont
atteint le Bureau Exécutif de
renaissance et donc ça plaide plutôt
qu'on continue à pouvoir s'exprimer les
uns et les autres parce que on ne
désespère pas qu'à la fin la convergence
de ce qu'on vous raconte ici et de ce
que les Français vont vous dire dans la
rue tout à l'heure vous permettent de
faire évoluer et en l'occurrence de
renoncer à ce texte
très bas très bien monsieur Bazin vous
avez la parole oui merci
bien sûr il y a plein de sujets à
évoquer il faut qu'on prenne le temps
quand il y a des points de pouvoir les
évoquer mais je pense qu'il faut qu'on
arrête de parler de la méthode de
discussion et qu'on se concentre sur les
différents points sur l'amendement en
question
je suis un peu interpellé parce que
la question du taux d'investissement de
l'entreprise dans la formation de ces
salariés de 55 ans et plus je pense que
l'enjeu se joue avant que si on veut
faire des reconversions réussie vers
d'autres métiers il faut que ça puisse
être anticipé et préparer et puis à un
moment le diable se cache dans les
détails vous avez des pyramides des âges
qui sont très variables en fonction des
entreprises certaines sont des
entreprises récentes auquel cas leur
public de plus de 55 ans et parfois
limité et d'autres ont surtout des
personnes beaucoup plus
âgées et peu de jeunes je pense que à
tel amendement
apporterait pas forcément de solutions
au taux d'emploi des seniors de manière
efficace parce qu'en réalité il faut
plutôt encourager et prévenir dans un
parcours de formation et c'est vrai que
il y a le sujet de la pénibilité il y a
aussi le sujet d'acquisition de
nouvelles connaissances avec des
domaines de formation
et je suis je suis pas sûr que le taux
d'investissement dans la formation de ce
salarié de 55 ans et plus soit le
critère le plus pertinent il me
semblerait plus intéressant de réfléchir
sur des parcours individualisés et qui
se joue beaucoup plus tôt dans le
parcours des salariés
très bien Madame Rousseau merci madame
la Présidente ce nom qui est question
ici c'est quand même d'un projet de
société ça n'est pas juste d'une réforme
budgétaire contrairement à ce que vous
essayez de nous présenter et donc il est
un peu normal aussi que nous prenions
temps de de discuter de chacun des
articles et particulièrement c'est vous
qui avez choisi l'ordre des articles et
de nous mettre l'index avant les
articles sur sur l'âge la pénibilité etc
et en fait cet ordre là nous nous incite
à discuter chaque article d'autant que
de ce que nous comprenons dans les
prises de parole publique à l'extérieur
de ces de cette hémicycle et de cette
commission c'est qu'en fait il n'y a
rien de négociable à part peut-être un
peu l'index donc nous jouons un plein
l'idée de d'amender cette index pour
faire en sorte qu'il soit contraignant
qu'il est un petit peu de substance et
qu'il ne soit pas juste de la décoration
donc nous continuerons à développer nos
arguments pour faire en sorte que au
moins sur la marge de manœuvre qui nous
est laissée très généreusement dans la
discussion de ce texte et bien nous
puissions imprimer notre marque sur la
question de la formation c'est aussi
dans cette c'est aussi dans cette
optique qu'il est très important de de
mettre en évidence les efforts de
formation qui sont faits par les
entreprises notamment à destination des
publics seniors parce qu'on sait que
notamment chez les emplois les plus
précaires et les moins qualifiés et bien
il y a des espèces de Trappes après
karité y compris à l'intérieur des
entreprises et c'est trap après karité
font que une fois qu'on est tombé dedans
et particulièrement quand on est femme
particulièrement quand on est senior
particulièrement quand on a un emploi
pénible et bien en fait on a plus la
capacité parce qu'on n'a pas accès à la
formation de sortir de ces métiers pour
faire d'autres métiers qui soient plus
et occupés d'autres emplois qui soient
moins pénis pour le corps donc en fait
il n'y a pas d'index seniors qui aurait
une quelconque substance sans cette
question de la formation et donc c'est
il est très important que l'on puisse
l'intégrer dans les obligations de cet
index
je rappelle la règle moi je suis pour
encore une fois faire en sorte qu'il y
ait un pour un contre mais juste qu'à
présence qui avait été actée c'est je le
dis pour les personnes qui nous ont
effectivement rejoint là aujourd'hui
c'est un par groupe une intervention par
groupe voilà ce qui a été acté
monsieur d'arriville
merci madame la Présidente je pense
effectivement que c'est que c'est la
bonne formule d'avoir une intervention
par groupe au minimum et si nous devions
mettre en cause cette règle je crains
que ça crée une jurisprudence très
problématique dans notre commission ce
que je vous le dis franchement je ne je
ne souhaite pas après ça je pense que
c'est la liberté aussi de chaque
parlementaire de pouvoir contribuer
participer et y compris au stade de la
Commission
à l'élaboration de la loi et à ce
travail que nous devons faire et qui est
qui est le cœur de notre de notre
mission alors je comprends bien
d'ailleurs monsieur Maillard tout à
l'heure nous a dit que finalement
l'objectif d'examiner toute la loi il y
avait renoncé et que il fallait au moins
discuter de ce qui est le cœur de la
mettre d'accord là-dessus d'ailleurs ce
qui est le cœur de la loi c'est
l'article 7 c'est le principal en fait
il y aurait que ça dans votre loi ça ça
vous suffirait c'est le recul de l'âge
légal donc bon c'est un aveu que vous
venez de faire et qui mais oui mais non
non c'est c'est le cœur c'est le
fondement le socle c'est c'est ce qui
est ce qui est l'essentiel pour vous bon
c'est c'est votre effectivement c'est
votre vision des choses c'est votre
projet de société ça n'est pas ça n'est
pas le nôtre moi je comprends un peu
cette impatience voilà mais moi la
question que j'ai envie de vous poser
aujourd'hui alors où déjà à cette
heure-ci les manifestants sont
rassemblés dans les rues de Marseille je
les salue au passage c'est où en
êtes-vous où en êtes-vous du retrait
parce que c'est ça la question qui se
pose en réalité alors je comprends bien
que vous me répondiez pas aujourd'hui
parce que sinon dans les rues de Paris
cet après-midi ça va être une grande
fête plutôt qu'une manifestation mais je
continue à vous poser cette question
parce que je crois que vous devriez vous
la poser vous n'y échapperez pas
très bien donc je mets pardon oui madame
la rapporteur oui mais d'accord monsieur
monsieur
ménager oui alors nous on n'a pas 4
groupes même si on s'interroge à faire
un RN1 RN2 RN3 RN4 pour monopoliser la
parole comme comme le font veiller la
nupaise depuis hier mais moi c'était
quand même assez apporté à un petit un
petit élément sur sur la bonne tenue des
débats c'est vrai que j'ai fait mes
calculs j'ai fait mes calculs il nous
reste 14 heures de débat il nous reste
5300 amendements 10 secondes par
amendement on passe actuellement 5
minutes par amendement et encore je je
suis optimiste si on passe 5 minutes par
un moment il y a 40 jours de débat
parce que là vous êtes les idiots utiles
du gouvernement vous allez nous empêcher
de parler du report de l'âge légal
aujourd'hui je sais bien que vous voulez
en faire plus vous voulez en faire des
caisses vous voulez en faire des caisses
pour faire oublier que vous avez voté
pour Monsieur Macron vous voulez en
faire des caisses parce que vous avez
vous êtes responsable de la réforme
Touraine des 43,8 mais madame la
Présidente propose un pour un contre moi
je vous propose de retirer je vous
propose de retirer vos amendements je
vous propose de d'être enfin intelligent
parce que là objectivement excepté
bordéliser et là pour une fois le Gérald
Darmanin a raison excepté bordéliser
cette commission vous ne servez à rien
vous êtes des idiots utiles vous faites
un cadeau incroyable au gouvernement
vous faites un cadeau incroyable vous
savez ils sont tous très contents de pas
parler du report de l'âge légal ils sont
tous très heureux donc à un moment soyez
un petit peu sérieux soyez un petit peu
sérieux les Français nous écoutent les
Français attendent qu'on les protège ils
attendent pas que vous soyez là en train
de juste faire votre petit cirque ils
attendent qu'on parle du fond des sujets
voilà retirez vos abonnements soyez un
petit peu intelligent et soyez là pas
pour défendre votre chapelle soyez là
pour défendre les Français vous oubliez
les Français dans cette histoire
très bien Madame la rapporteur qui
souhaitait s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît
madame la rapporteur elle seule à la
parole s'il vous plaît nous merci merci
madame la Présidente
s'il vous plaît
je voudrais répondre à Madame Rousseau
qui dit qu'on a choisi l'ordre des
articles mais en fait non c'est lié à la
loi organique qui nous demande
d'examiner la partie recette avant la
partie dépense donc on choisit pas
l'ordre de l'examen des textes pour
répondre à Monsieur dareville
il dit que l'article 7 seul nous
suffirait mais je suis pas d'accord avec
cette remarque puisque l'article 7 qui
recule l'âge permet d'avoir 18 milliards
d'économies dans cette réforme mais il y
a aussi un tiers de de cette réforme qui
concerne des mesures d'accompagnement 6
milliards dans cette réforme et dans
l'étude d'impact et c'est 6 milliards
concernent toutes les mesures
d'accompagnement que sont les départs
avant l'âge légal qui concerne les
articles 8 et 9 les petites pensions les
carrières longues le cumul emploi
retraite les retraites progressives ça
c'est l'article 13 donc moi j'ai tout à
fait envie qu'on poursuive jusqu'à ces
articles enfin pour répondre à Monsieur
Guedj effectivement on continue les
échanges avec avec la population bien
entendu avec les organisations
syndicales et tant mieux si ce texte
évolue tout au long de ce parcours c'est
ça le débat parlementaire et pour en
revenir à l'amendement d'ailleurs ces
organisations syndicales que nous avons
auditionné dans le cadre de nos travaux
nous ont pas demandé de préciser ces
indicateurs
merci Madame la rapporteur donc je mets
aux voix ces deux amendements qui ont
reçu un avis défavorable alors déjà tout
d'abord le 847 qui est pour
qui est contre il est rejeté même ma vie
même vote pour l'amendement suivant bon
je le mets aux voix qui est pour
qui est contre il est rejeté monsieur
s'il vous plaît
monsieur aviranier et lui seul à la
parole merci madame la Présidente alors
dans le même ordre d'esprit un
amendement pour pour mettre en place un
indicateur spécifique cette fois-ci sur
la mobilité professionnelle qui semble
un point incontournable sur
dans ce texte
très bien Madame la rapporteur
défavorable très bien je mets aux voix
cet amendement qui a reçu un avis
défavorable qui est pour
qui est contre il est rejeté amendement
pouvant être mis en discussion comme une
Monsieur Antoine non monsieur Monet
merci madame la Présidente c'est juste
que si on a l'ambition de faire reculer
l'âge de
retraite tout en agissant sur les
conditions d'emploi des seniors il faut
intégrer
dans les indicateurs les licenciements
pour inaptitude et leur reclassement
pour inaptitude c'est ce qu'on demande
très bien Madame la rapporteur
non mais il n'est pas défendu pardon
défavorable très bien je mets aux voix
cet amendement qui a reçu un avis
défavorable qui est pour qui
est contre
il est rejeté amendement suivant madame
rigole madame Rousseau qui le défend le
et bien je peux le défendre c'est
amendement supprime la possibilité
laisser un accord de branche de déroger
aux indicateurs et aux méthodes de
calcul déterminées par décret relatifs à
l'emploi des seniors en effet cette
mesure reviendrait à vider de la déjà
maigre substance cette disposition on en
a parlé hier laissez libre arbitre aux
branche c'est laisser aussi la
possibilité que certaines branches ne
reconnaissent pas la pénibilité à la
même hauteur que d'autres et en
l'occurrence il est extrêmement
important que nous ayons des indicateurs
qui soient trans qui transforment des
branches particulièrement sur le port de
charge lourdes mais aussi sur les
postures pénibles sur l'exposition aux
produits chimiques etc je reprends
l'exemple des aides à domicile qui me
tient à cœur elles font partie des
personnes qui sont le plus exposées aux
produits chimiques parce qu'elles font
le ménage avec des produits qui ne sont
pas standardisés dans des conditions de
sécurité qui ne sont pas toujours
toujours assurés et par conséquent on ne
peut pas laisser aux branches et
particulièrement les branches dans
lesquelles il y a très peu de
syndicalisation donc de défense des
intérêts des salariés la possibilité de
choisir leur propre critères dans cette
index
la rapporteur nous faisons confiance aux
branches pour être au plus près des
réalités des entreprises donc avis
défavorable très bien donc je mets aux
voix cet amendement qui a reçu un avis
oui monsieur Clouet
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente je
pense que c'est amendement il est là
aussi important parce qu'il pose une
question qui anime depuis longtemps
cette commission et y compris durant
différentes alternances c'est le rapport
entre la règle au niveau national et la
règle au niveau des branches et ce
rapport il est fondamental parce que la
base notre démocratie sociale c'est le
principe de faveur à savoir le fait que
les branches sont couvertes par un texte
de loi et en étant couverte elles
permettent de de l'améliorer uniquement
mais jamais d'idées pour le moins 10 ans
ici un des risques que pose cette index
senior c'est finalement qu'il permette
d'être vidé de son sens par des
négociations de branches qui auraient un
rapport concurrentiel d'une branche à
l'autre chacune est sans tirer vers le
bas le peu de bénéfice dont on pourrait
retirer de l'index seniors finalement ce
qui se joue ici c'est de savoir c'est
index senior ne servira juste à rien ou
sera néfaste je préfère que ça va rien
très bien monsieur breton oui merci
madame la Présidente oui je crois que ça
révèle les positions sur cet amendement
les divergences qu'on peut avoir sur le
dialogue social c'est la manière dont il
fait je crois qu'on peut avoir confiance
aux négociations ou dialogues qui se
passe dans chaque branche c'est une
vision de la subsidiarité c'est
effectivement de voir au plus près du
terrain avec des gens qui s'organisent
et là d'avoir de vouloir effectivement
tout centraliser toute nationaliser
entre guillemets je crois que ça va pas
dans le bon sens et moi personnellement
je reste attaché un dialogue social qui
soit au plus près du terrain et
là-dessus au delà de ce qu'on peut
penser de cette année senior c'est
important de pouvoir garder les branches
comme étant le bon niveau de décision et
de proposition
Rousseau
oui je rappelle que selon les branches
les encore une fois le taux de
syndicalisation est donc la force des
syndicats pour négocier la
reconnaissance des des carrières
difficiles hachées de la pénibilité
n'est pas la même et particulièrement
dans les branches féminisées ou les le
travail en miettes et les conditions de
travail ne favorisent pas une
syndicalisation très forte des
personnels ce qui fait que la pénibilité
encore une fois des femmes et des femmes
les plus précaires et et la pire et la
non reconnue et il a moins reconnu donc
là maintenant il suffit d'arrêter cette
espèce d'hypocrisie selon lesquelles
toutes les branches seraient égales dans
la dans la définition et dans la
négociation des critères de pénibilité
de formation etc et dire que l'État a un
rôle à jouer dans le dans l'égalité et
l'équité assuré des salariés en
l'occurrence là vous avez la possibilité
de voter cette égalité vraiment soyez
responsable très bien Monsieur Martin
oui merci madame la Présidente on
comprend très bien à vous écouter que
les oppositions politiques aujourd'hui
sont au service des syndicats je dirais
plutôt à la remorque des syndicats ils
essaient de trouver leur place dans ce
mouvement syndical auquel nous allons
assister aujourd'hui
néanmoins néanmoins le dialogue social
dans notre pays est repose sur
l'existence s'il
vous plaît merci néanmoins
le dialogue social et les avancées
sociales reposent sur la négociation de
branches métiers par métier branche par
branche en fonction des risques
d'exposition qui sont sensiblement
différents d'un côté et de l'autre donc
ce sont 5 millions de personnes qui sont
concernées par cette évolution et le
ministre du Travail
propose dans ce texte des avancées
importantes sur le compte professionnel
de prévention le C2P avec en particulier
le déplafonnement du nombre de points et
l'organisation de départ anticipé et
d'évolution et de changer de métier par
conséquent je pense que nous devons
rester dans ce texte je pense aussi que
nous pèse montre sa grande
variété de position puisque les uns sont
pour les autres sont contre ils nous ont
exposés que l'index ne servait
strictement à rien et maintenant ils
veulent effectivement l'enrichir avec de
multiples amendements on a du pas la
suivre le raisonnement
très bien très bien monsieur Bazin s'il
vous plaît madame la rapporteur oui
juste pour répondre à Madame Rousseau
que nous avons adopté hier l'amendement
de madame rixin qui pose le principe que
l'index devra comprendre des indicateurs
genre donc c'était satisfait pour les
femmes en tout cas très bien non on
relance pas le débat je mets aux voix
cet amendement qui a reçu un avis
défavorable qui est pour
qui est contre il est rejeté madame
Beretti
l'amendement 5000 10 pardon 5717 madame
la Présidente mes chers collègues je me
demandais comment nous pourrions
effectuer des comparaisons entre
branches sur les mesures de l'index
senior si nous laissons ces mêmes
branches les finir chacune leurs propres
critères je vous soumets donc un
amendement qui propose de rendre
obligatoire la négociation de branche en
matière d'indicateurs et de méthode de
calcul sur l'index senior via un switch
entre les verbes pouvoir et devoir je
pense que l'index Seigneur ne peut être
pertinent que si les critères sont
discutés paritairement et si la reflète
des typologies de métiers la pyramide
des âges la réalité de terrain et
surtout les risques qui pèsent sur un
secteur donné je vous remercie madame la
rapporteur c'est un avis défavorable car
nous devons aussi prévoir le cas où cet
accord ne serait pas possible
monsieur Clouet vous avez demandé la
parole monsieur le député merci beaucoup
madame la Présidente c'est un amendement
qui est intéressant à double titre
d'abord évidemment parce qu'il durcit
l'index en question et donc ça participe
de tout ce que nous essayons de défendre
depuis quelques jours je me réjouis que
ça se dit que ça se diffuse et qu'on
soit d'accord là-dessus et deuxièmement
parce que l'amendement fait une
distinction au verbale intéressante un
remplacer le verbe pouvoir par devoir
comme par exemple dans la situation
suivante vous pouvez retirer le texte il
me semble qu'au vu des manifestations
aujourd'hui vous devez retirer le texte
très bien Madame la Députée vous
maintenez votre amendement
vous maintenez votre amendement très
bien donc amendement retirer madame
louvagi vous avez la parole oui merci
madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur je crois que nous avons deux
points sur lesquels nous pouvons tous
nous retrouver et que nous reconnaissons
que l'emploi des seniors est un sujet en
France que la France est plutôt mauvaise
élève et le deuxième point c'est que
nous avons tous envie de voir l'emploi
des seniors s'améliorer si l'article 2
prévoit une procédure qui doit
accompagner le relèvement de l'âge légal
de départ à la retraite sa difficulté
finalement sera dans sa mise en oeuvre
moi je suis persuadée qu'il faut
encourager prévenir et qu'il faut
laisser beaucoup de latitude de dialogue
et de concertation il faudrait surtout
éviter que les indicateurs puissent se
comparer je veux donner un exemple la
branche Syntec qui regroupe les
entreprises du numérique a souvent une
moyenne d'âge des salariés basses en
revanche des entreprises de formation
professionnelle par exemple ont une
moyenne d'âge plus élevée faut
véritablement que nous évitions des
comparaisons d'indicateurs donc pour
cela il faut laisser beaucoup de
latitude aux branches professionnelles
il faut tenir compte des spécificités
des métiers de leurs évolutions c'est la
raison pour laquelle je vous propose
d'enlever cette fixation des conditions
définies par voie réglementaire et de
laisser aux conventions aux branches
toute latitude tout en ayant prévu à la
Linéa précédent et je le laisse que la
liste les indicateurs et leur méthode
des calculs soient fixées par décret
mais je pense que cela est suffisant au
niveau de la voie réglementaire c'est
l'objet de cet amendement
très bien donc je mets aux voix
rapporteur pardon c'est un avis
défavorable parce que mais il me semble
que c'est presque satisfait parce que la
voie réglementaire elle va permettre de
dire dans quel cadre les négociations
vont se faire en fait elle va favoriser
que les négociations se fassent donc
c'est plutôt
quasi satisfait ou défavorable
très bien monsieur Viry
on sait très bien que l'emploi des
seniors ça fait je reprends ce qui a pu
être dit ça fait effectivement 6 ou 7
heures qu'on est sur l'index ici sur
cette heure sur un index qui va pas
bouleverser le taux d'emploi des seniors
ça fait effectivement un peu beaucoup
après c'est un sujet de société me
semble-t-il que le projet de loi tel
qu'il est qu'il est proposé en termes de
réforme des retraites il est bien
insuffisant et il me semble qu'au-delà
d'appel fssr il faudra aller à terme
vers un paquet législatif majeur sur le
sujet ou alors ou alors inviter vraiment
un des États généraux avec les
partenaires sociaux pour qu'on
s'interroge sur le rapport au travail
des travailleurs expérimentés parce
qu'on n'y est pas et moi je trouvais
effectivement que c'est amendement il
permet effectivement de se dire faisons
confiance au dialogue social demandant
partenaire sociaux de trouver les
ressorts donc j'ai bien senti madame la
rapporteur que vous hésitiez disons que
c'est satisfait et que c'était un avis
défavorable par défaut moi j'avais tes
collègues à soutenir cet amendement qui
qui n'emporte rien surface qu'on laisse
de la liberté sur le terrain et surtout
qu'on se donne la chance d'augmenter le
taux d'emploi des seniors
très bien donc je mets aux voix cet
amendement qui a reçu un avis
défavorable qui est pour
qui est contre il est rejeté amendement
pouvant être mis en discussion commune
monsieur aviranier oui merci madame la
Présidente donc là on a demandé pour pas
laisser la possibilité à la branche
d'établir des indicateurs sur l'emploi
des seniors - 10 ans que le décret qui
sera évidemment pris à cet effet
madame la rapporteur c'est un avis
défavorable
pardon il y a un amendement monsieur
Petavy excusez-moi je vous ai zappé
alors déjà hier maintenant aujourd'hui
peut-être demain
alors en regardant dans les détails de
cet hiver ce qui permet potentiellement
aux entreprises de s'acheter une bonne
conscience à Bakou nous nous rendons
compte que les entreprises ne sont non
seulement pas obligées de publier mais
cet article ouvre la voie une
possibilité d'adaptation de l'index par
branche si l'adaptation de l'index peut
faciliter une adaptation des indicateurs
à chaque milieu professionnel nous y
voyons surtout un risque dans ces
indicateurs soient revu à la baisse en
cas de rapport de force défavorable aux
salariés seniors nous y voyons surtout
un risque réel de dégradation des
conditions d'emplois pour les seniors
avec des indicateurs ou rabais le groupe
écologiste appelle donc à l'encadrement
des modalités d'adaptation des
indicateurs par branche donc nous
demandons donc à ce que toute nouvelle
modification des indicateurs par rapport
par accord de branche excusez-moi ou
convention n'entraîne pas une
dévalorisation des indicateurs
déterminés par décret
très bien Madame la rapporteur
alors je vous donne le micro allez-y il
y a pas de notion de moins 10 ans ou de
mieux de 10 ans parce que ce sont des
indicateurs donc il y a des notions de
objectif à ces indicateurs donc à écrire
dans la loi des -10 ans mieux 10 ans
c'est pas
c'est pas législatif donc avis
défavorable madame Rousseau
précisément vous pointez là du doigt
madame la rapporteur exactement le sujet
pour lequel il faut voter cet amendement
c'est le sujet essentiel c'est à dire
qu'il y a rien d'obligatoire dans cet
index il y a rien de contraignant il y a
aucune espèce de mesure commune aux
branche enfin vraiment là on a atteint
l'espèce de transparence complète d'un
dispositif qui n'a aucun sens donc voté
au moins cet indicateur qui permet
d'avoir une petite consistance dans
l'index très bien monsieur Bazin
merci madame la Présidente on est sur un
sujet important c'est est-ce qu'on fait
confiance aux paris Thaïs c'est ce qu'on
fait confiance en accord de branche
on écoute monsieur le député
des avancées qui sont issus du dialogue
social d'ailleurs souvent le dialogue
social est parfois
en pointe par rapport à ce qu'on peut
même imaginer ici la question qui se
pose c'est vous dites mon indicateur que
celle fixé par décret on a aujourd'hui
une procédure d'agrément des accords de
branches qui qui suit est-ce qu'on règle
tout a priori ou à posteriori moi j'ai
plutôt tendance à dire aujourd'hui
qui peut avoir un dialogue fécond
et qui et d'une certaine manière après
l'état vient vérifier que les éléments
sont
corrects et notamment les indicateurs
plutôt que de préciser ça par la voie
réglementaire a priori je pense au
contraire qu'il faut laisser un peu de
flexibilité sachant que en fonction des
branches il y a des spécificités qu'il
faut pouvoir construire et que n'est pas
forcément dans le champ du du décret
faut même aller au-delà on le voit bien
sur la retraite progressive il y a l'âge
légal moins 2 or finalement dans les
branches il peut avoir des choses qui se
combinent qui se construisent notamment
sur la pénibilité ou ils iront peut-être
même au-delà des indicateurs fixés par
décret parce que ces indicateurs
spécifiques à la branche donc moi je
suis pas favorable à cette à cet
amendement je crois au contraire qui qui
faut faire confiance au dialogue social
sachant qu'en plus il y a cette
procédure d'agrément 4 mois après qui
peut être prolongé deux mois il me
semble pour pouvoir agréer l'accord de
branche pour vérifier qu'il correspond à
un certain nombre d'éléments
très bien Madame La Valette madame la
Présidente merci voilà encore une fois 5
heures de débat sur l'index il est temps
de passer autre chose alors je vois bien
que la nuit pèse ce matin est excitée
comme une mariée qui va à l'hôtel il
n'empêche que garder garder un peu
d'énergie mes chers collègues mes chers
collègues garder un peu d'énergie
gardez madame Rousseau détendez-vous
gardez un peu garder un peu d'énergie
pour voter
pour voter s'il vous plaît pour voter
notre émotion référendaire puisque c'est
la nôtre qui va être présenté les
Français ne comprendraient pas que vous
ne la votiez pas alors de grâce
éparpitiez mes chers collègues laisser
de côté votre incontinence législative
qui parasite le débat s'il vous plaît
retirez vos amendements nous arrivions
enfin au coeur du sujet que nous
arrivions enfin à ce qui à ce qui
concerne évidemment les Français le cœur
nucléaire qui l'article 7 merci un peu
de faire preuve de même de de démocratie
à un moment où l'embolie ça commence à
bien faire merci
monsieur léoman s'il vous plaît on se
calme on se calme merci merci Madame
Laprée s'il vous plaît merci madame la
Présidente simplement pour redire à nos
collègues du rassemblement national je
ne sais combien de fois nous avons dû
leur dire que s'il voulait que nous
avons station plus vite sur le l'article
2 il fallait tout simplement voter
l'amendement de suppression que nous
avons proposé hier alors de deux choses
l'une soit nos collègues du
rassemblement national ne suivent pas
l'examen du texte sont à la ramasse qui
me semble le plus probable option 2 il
se il se prévalent de turpitude c'est à
dire il ne vote pas puis ensuite il se
plaignent du fait qu'il y a un débat un
vraiment ça commence à être très
fatigant si vous n'avez pas envie de
travailler dans cette commission partez
enfin en fait autre chose quoi allez
vous promener si ça vous ennuie de
débattre sur cette index senior qui
effectivement est inutile mais qui doit
mériter un débat approfondi puisque vous
avez refusé de voter la suppression au
tout début de l'examen alors moi
vraiment je pense mais vraiment je pense
que vous étiez à la ramasse que vous
suiviez pas parce que quand vous quittez
votre feuille de vote et que vous vous
levez un instant les yeux de cette
feuille de vote vous semblez totalement
perdu et je dois dire que c'est assez
étonnant pour des députés d'être
incapable de suivre un texte tout seul
donc de grâce arrêtez avec vos leçons à
deux balles et essayer un peu de vous
reconcentrer sur le texte car nous avons
un examen qui va durer longtemps puisque
nous avons jusqu'à mercredi soir pour
débattre de cette index inutile ou
d'autres choses plus ou moins inutiles
et enfin pour voter bien sûr contre
l'article 7 quand nous y arriverons mais
soyez là au moment de l'article de
suppression de l'article 7 de
l'amendement de suppression de l'article
7 car ce serait dommage que vous ne le
que que vous ne le votiez pas
très bien
donc je mets au je mets aux voix donc
ces amendements qui ont reçu un avis
défavorable pour le 859 s'il vous plaît
qui est pour
qui est contre il est rejeté amendement
suivant le 37 60 même avis même vote
même avis même vote il est donc rejeté
monsieur Petavy vous avez la parole sur
l'amendement
nous avons un index qui donne la main
aux entreprises qui leur demandent
gentiment de ne pas oublier d'envoyer
leurs résultats aussi misérable ses
résultats soient-ils cet index senior en
dit long sur le désintérêt du
gouvernement envers nos aînés c'est un
index 440 compatible fait pour que les
entreprises se lavent les mains sans
bouger le petit doigt oui décidément
c'est une histoire de doigt ce texte oui
vous pour l'amélioration de l'emploi et
de l'emploi de qualité des seniors c'est
un index qui en l'état actuel ne fera
rien pour les 60,2 % des chômeurs de
longue durée de 55 ans et plus pour les
seniors qui envoient des centaines de CV
pendant des années qui finissent
désespérer par attendre dans la
précarité l'arrivée de l'âge légal de la
retraite par cet amendement nous
appelons à des sanctions réellement
exigeantes et dissuasives pour que la
discrimination massive à l'égard des
seniors ne deviennent plus une option
financière viable pour les entreprises
au-delà de la sanction pouvant aller
jusqu'à 1% de la salariale qui est
davantage symbolique nous appelons au
conditionnement des exonérations des
cotisations pour les entreprises au
respect des indicateurs par cet
amendement nous rappelons nous appelons
à ce que les 160 milliards de cadeaux
fiscaux aux entreprises soit enfin
conditionnées à des critères non
seulement environnementaux mais aussi
sociaux à savoir le respect de la
dignité de nos aînés dans leur travail
très bien Madame la rapporteur
je vous donne le micro oui merci madame
la Présidente c'est un avis défavorable
vous dites que 1% de la masse salariale
pour des entreprises le plus de 300
salariés fait rien je suis pas d'accord
avec vous et puis on aura ensuite dans
les amendements qui arrivent là sur les
sur les le débat sur les exonérations
donc avis des favorables très bien donc
je mets pardon madame Guérin
merci je suis profondément choquée par
le RN qui brille par sa vision moderne
de la place des femmes donc hier on a eu
droit à la politique la Nathalie ce
matin on a droit à la mariée donc là moi
je parlerai plutôt d'un continent
conservatrice et rétrograde pour revenir
à l'index on a un taux d'emploi des
55,64 ans qui sont qui est de 56 % on a
un taux de précarité le plus faible en
Europe ou presque et ça doit rester
comme ça je vous permets pas de parler
de mon apparence physique Madame La
Valette donc ce texte on y revient c'est
une coquille vide et pourtant vous
refusez les objectifs qu'on a proposé on
a proposé par exemple un score minimal
vous l'avez refusé donc à un moment
donné madame la rapporter si vous pouvez
pas nous parler d'objectif et quand on
vous fait des propositions d'objectifs
concrets vous le refusez j'entends des
collègues qui nous parlent de
paritarisme alors d'un côté on nous on
nous suspecte d'être à la boîte des
syndicats et de l'autre on nous parle de
paritarisme on nous dit qu'il faut le
remettre en place mais l'assurance
chômage précisément avec en décidant des
modalités par décret elle sinon
s'éloignait du paritarisme là on a tous
les syndicats qui sont opposés à cette
il y a personne personne à droite pour
l'entendre alors nous dire qu'on est à
la bonne des syndicats c'est bien
sympathique mais les syndicats ils ont
leur rôle ils représentent des
travailleurs ils ont permis des
victoires et du progrès social dans le
passé et aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression
qu'il se retrouve confronté à un espèce
de mépris qui est choquant et une vision
du dialogue social qui est choquante
aussi et finalement on a l'impression
qu'on a un gouvernement qui s'enlise
dans un refus d'écouter la
représentation des travailleurs et je
trouve que on pourrait on gagnerait à
écouter une intercer syndicale qui s'est
enfin uni ces dernières années et qui
vous le dit elle-même en audition si
tout le monde est d'accord d'un côté et
que vous êtes les seuls à être pas
d'accord c'est probablement qu'il y a un
problème
très bien donc je mets aux voix cet
amendement qui a reçu un avis
défavorable qui est pour
qui est contre il est rejeté monsieur
Petavy amendement 6815
alors nous entendons depuis tout à
l'heure dire que non cette réforme
nauséabonde n'inclut pas seulement
l'index seniors mais aussi les
négociations au sein des entreprises sur
l'emploi des seigneurs nous rappelons
que la question de l'emploi des seniors
était déjà une disposition prévue dans
la négociation sur la gestion des
emplois et des parcours professionnels
et cela n'empêche pas les entreprises de
continuer à discriminer massivement le
Seigneur comment expliquer dans ces
cas-là que 89% des seniors ressentent
l'âge comme un facteur discriminant car
je pense que depuis tout à l'heure peu
d'efforts ont été faits pour se mettre à
la place des seniors est-ce que vous
savez ce que c'est d'avoir passé 40 ans
de sa vie à construire sa carrière à
avoir acquis des compétences complexes à
maîtriser son outil de travail son
métier pour finalement nous faire sentir
comme des salariés jetables pour que
l'entreprise
pour laquelle on a donné 5 ans 10 ans 40
ans de sa vie et la majorité de son
temps nous traite comme des inutiles
est-ce que vous savez ce que c'est que
d'avoir subi des tendinites des maladies
respirates respiratoires ou le burn out
pour devoir revenir à la case départ et
rechercher un nouveau travail aussi
éreintant jusqu'à atteindre l'âge légal
inscrire une ligne de plus dans le code
du travail et demandez poliment aux
entreprises de publier un questionnaire
c'est un manque cruel d'ambition pour
que les entreprises respectent enfin les
seniors et c'est parce que les
entreprises n'ont aucun intérêt
financier à garder les seniors que nous
devons passer la vitesse supérieure en
conditionnant les milliards d'euros
d'exonération fiscale à la conclusion
d'un accord sur l'emploi des seniors les
toits l'État doit reprendre toutes ses
responsabilités en cessant de signer des
chèques en blanc aux entreprises sans
aucune condition ni demande sur l'emploi
et le maintien sans emploi d'essai
salarié âgé merci
très bien Madame la rapporteur
très bien Madame Rousseau
micro je vous le donne
je voudrais venir en soutien de
l'amendement de mon collègue Sébastien
Petavy parce que c'est un amendement qui
est vraiment extrêmement important en
réalité c'est à dire que l'idée d'avoir
une convention et un accord de branche
relatif à la formation et on maintient
en emploi des seniors qui soit corrélés
à la publication de l'index nous
permettrait en fait de mettre un plan
d'action sur l'augmentation de l'emploi
des seniors dans les entreprises et en
fait c'est ça qui manque dans cet index
outre le fait qu'il y a pas de sanctions
outre le fait que il ne contient rien et
surtout rien obligatoire mais là en fait
avec le plan d'action il nous
permettrait d'aller vers une meilleure
vers un meilleur taux d'emploi des
seniors et même ça en fait votre
objectif est d'augmenter le taux
d'emploi ça se voit bon bah très bien il
faut augmenter le plus le taux d'emploi
des seniors en effet on a un détour
d'emploi des seniors les plus faibles
d'Europe mais comment on le fait et bien
il n'y a rien dans cette loi qui nous
permet de le dire et là en l'occurrence
c'est une opportunité pour pouvoir
savoir entreprise par entreprise au plus
près du terrain comme vous le disiez
madame rapporteur au plus près des
branches aussi comment nous allons
pouvoir faire un plan de compensation
des de sous-emploi des de sous-emploi
des seniors donc en fait non on a une
espèce de solution pratique quelque
chose de vraiment très concret pour
faire que de cette index un outil vers
une amélioration de l'emploi des seniors
très bien Madame Monsieur Clouet pardon
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente cet
amendement je viens évidemment en
soutien pour deux raisons la première
c'est bien entendu parce qu'il tente de
donner un peu de substances à cette
index toujours aussi fantomatique
deuxièmement c'est parce que pour se
faire il propose de revenir en tout cas
de conditionner donc de revenir
partiellement sur les exonérations de
cotisations sociales cette politique qui
est menée dans notre pays depuis plus de
30 ans et qui n'a toujours pas fait ses
preuves enfin si elle a fait ses preuves
en termes de ruines pour les budgets
sociaux et pour les comptes publics
puisque on sait bien que désormais elles
ne sont plus que partiellement
compensées par l'État donc elle coûte
cher à la sécurité sociale c'est
exonération elle coûte cher aux caisses
d'assurance vieillesse c'est d'ailleurs
une des raisons pour lesquelles
apparemment nous sommes là puisque vous
voulez trouver 12 milliards en
l'occurrence nos collègues vous en
proposent 66 il me semble que le
rendement est assez bon pour un petit
bout de papier 66 milliards ça rapporte
et on est dans une situation qui est
d'autant plus paradoxale que les volumes
d'exonération de cotisation sociale sont
sup à l'impôt sur les sociétés donc on
paye les entreprises au final pour
produire ça me semble quand même très
étonnant dans ce pays de voir leur
verser plus en exonération que ce
qu'elle rapporte un impôt sur les
sociétés alors je sais que sur le plan
global vous êtes favorable vous
cotisation sociale et on va pas
forcément mener un débat général ici on
propose de les circonscrire légèrement
faire en sorte que dès lors que la
société la société au sens l'entreprise
d'établissement maltraite les
travailleurs seigneurs ou expérimentés
en son sein et bien le bénéfice des
exonérations ne soient pas conservées ça
me semble extrêmement raisonnable et
peut-être une voix pour faire enfin
cette co-construction que nous espérons
toutes et tous
très bien donc je mets aux voix cet
amendement qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de Madame Lara porter qui
est pour
qui contre il est rejeté Monsieur
aviranier Vous AVEZ LA PAROLE monsieur
califère merci Madame
nous sommes toujours sur le chemin de la
construction ou même de d'un effort que
nous faisons donner un peu de
consistance dans l'index et nous
proposons simplement là que
une mesure qui vise à ce qu'un
inspection du travail puisse contrôler
plus contrôler les entreprises ayant
publié n'ayant pas publié leur index on
dit pas droit mais donner la possibilité
à l'inspection du travail de contrôler
satisfait parce que les données seront
publiques donc l'inspection du travail
peut tout à fait sans satisfaire donc
c'est plutôt une demande de retrait ou
avis des favorable
non c'est pas vous il y a quelqu'un qui
a demandé madame Rousseau
supprimer cette réforme des retraites
qui n'a aucun sens monsieur Maillard
merci madame la Présidente oui je sais
pas si vous avez déjà assisté à un
contrôle du travail mais évidemment les
contours de travail ont accès à
l'ensemble des données sociales et c'est
de public et donc ils auront évidemment
accès à l'ensemble de ces données donc
je comprends pas bien c'est redondant ça
existe déjà et mais même en amont les
inspections du travail qui arrivent dans
une entreprise a accès à l'intégralité
des données sociales donc je comprends
pas bien ce que la difficulté que vous
voyez dedans si ce n'est de faire un
mauvais procès à ce texte très bien
monsieur califer
voilà merci Madame brise ce qu'on
n'arrive pas à comprendre monsieur
Maillard c'est que il y a cette
résistance là à ne pas donner la
consistance à l'index si l'index visa
renforcer
l'emploi des aînés seniors à maintenir
les signaux quoi de plus naturel qu'il y
ait des dispositifs qui accompagnent dès
le départ le contrôle vient après il est
inopiné il y a des entreprises qui ne
sont pas contrôlés
en plus il y a pas de contrôle
ils sont très peu nombreux donc si nous
voulons véritablement une partageons
tout cela faire en sorte que les seniors
soient embauchés et reste sont maintenus
dans le branche quoi depuis naturel que
permettre un spectre l'inspection du
travail d'avoir l'information ne pas
aller le chercher dans un journal on a
un problème avec publié c'est
l'inspection du travail il n'y a pas sur
les réseaux sociaux chercher est-ce que
voilà un peu ce qu'on nous demande tout
simplement
très bien alors sur ce
pardon oui monsieur cloué
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
alors c'est amendement il est évidemment
de bon sens évidemment utile puisque il
se situe et malheureusement on va voir
un peu de redit en amont d'un contrôle
il s'agit de donner des moyens
supplémentaires à la fois en termes de
connaissances en terme de capacité
d'intervention en termes de
compréhension de la situation en amont
d'un contrôle et faire ça en amont ça
permet à la fois d'améliorer la balle
c'est le principe de la moindre la balle
généralement il y a un lien logique
entre les deux être meilleur pour
préparer le contrôle savoir un contrôle
plus efficace plus opérationnel et qui
fait gagner du temps et franchement
l'inspection du travail bah non c'est
pas déjà le cas bah il n'existe pas
d'index ça peut être le cas bon donc
donc une fois que vous avez une
information en amont qui existe
l'inspection et en capacité de mieux
structurer de mieux organiser
l'intervention sur le terrain donc il
s'agit de gagner du temps pour les
professionnels et de savoir où jeter
l'oeil ou regarder dans le monde de
l'entreprise bref d'avoir des contrôles
sur pièces et sur place qui sont tout
simplement plus efficaces et plus
rentable en termes de contrôle de la
légalité de la conformité très bien
Madame la rapporteur vous souhaitiez je
veux juste dire que là on est en train
de écrire un texte de loi et que
l'amendement qui est proposé ne dit pas
ce que vous dites qui est d'ailleurs par
ailleurs satisfait à mon avis donc je
redis un avis défavorable sur cet
amendement très bien donc je mets aux
voix cet amendement qui a reçu un avis
défavorable qui est pour
qui est contre il est rejeté amendement
suivant
madame Hugues
merci madame la Présidente
le présent amendement que je défends
pour mon collègue Raphaël Gérard propose
d'adosser à l'index seigneur des
indicateurs relatifs à la diversité dans
l'emploi je m'explique la 13e édition du
baromètre de la perception des
discriminations publiées par le
Défenseur des droits et l'Organisation
internationale du Travail publiée en
décembre 2020 documente les conséquences
délétères et durables des comportements
discriminatoires répétés sur les
individus et leur parcours de vie ces
discriminations constituent un frein à
l'embauche à la promotion
professionnelle ce qui alimente les
inégalités salariales épaissent sur le
niveau des pensions à l'heure actuelle
diverses dispositions du Code du travail
permettent de prévenir ou de corriger
les effets de ces discriminations
notamment lorsqu'elles sont fondées sur
le sexe ou la situation de handicap du
salarié les entreprises et les
organisations publiques savent mesurer
la diversité et le niveau d'inclusion
lié au handicap à l'âge et au genre
néanmoins il conviendrait de prendre
davantage en considération à la fois la
multiplicité des comportements hostiles
au travail leurs dimensions systémiques
et les situations particulières de
certains groupes qui sont surexposés
pour répondre à cet objectif le
gouvernement a donc lancé à titre
expérimental un index diversité et
inclusion dans le but de favoriser
l'égalité d'accès aux opportunités dans
l'emploi ainsi que la reconnaissance et
la valorisation de compétences de tout
de tous les salariés de toutes les
salariés afin d'amplifier cette
initiative donc le présente amendement
et déposer
sur la rigidification des des
indicateurs
très bien
donc vous le maintenez madame la députée
votre amendement ah je me suis
Coulommiers avant
Coulommes
alors pour une fois on va être d'accord
avec cet amendement effectivement tant
qu'à faire un index autant que on le on
le destine à mesurer également les
discriminations qui peuvent exister dans
les entreprises par rapport au handicap
notamment donc on est plutôt favorable à
ce dispositif mais je voudrais quand
même poser la question de pourquoi on
est capable d'avoir des mesures de
coercition extrêmement sévères qui vont
finir en 49-3 pour pour ses retraites
qui va être une forme d'imposition
radicale et fanatisée à l'ensemble des
des Françaises et des Français sur ce
projet de loi de contre-réforme de
retraite et puis finalement quand il
s'agit de mettre des indicateurs et bien
là on est dans une connivence dans une
tolérance
qui ne fait preuve d'aucune coercition
finalement pour les entreprises pour les
obliger à être vertueuse par rapport à
leur stratégie
des salariés donc c'est quand même
étonnant qu'on soit capable finalement
d'être aussi confiant dans la vertu des
entreprises et aussi sévère dans ce que
l'on impose aux salariés y compris aux
salariés qui sont dans des situations de
handicap donc nous nous serons plutôt
pour cette amendement mais encore une
fois chers collègues moi je vous invite
à vous poser la question pourquoi est-ce
qu'on fait preuve de coercition
vis-à-vis des Françaises et des Français
et de d'une très grande bienveillance et
d'une très grande tolérance d'une grande
confiance d'une grande mensuétude
exactement dans lactisme exactement
chers collègues avec les entreprises
dont on préjuge finalement quels seront
honnêtes bienveillantes avec l'ensemble
des salariés y compris les salariés en
situation de handicap
très bien oui madame Garin
merci pour nous les écologistes on
soutiendra aussi cet amendement et je
suis un petit peu désolée que même quand
il y a de très bonnes idées dans vos
rangs vous n'y soyez pas favorables on
sait que le monde du travail c'est un
des premiers lieux de la discrimination
donc il y a vraiment urgence à agir de
ce côté-là on parle bien entendu des
inégalités de genre avec beaucoup de
difficultés d'accès à l'emploi je crois
que un des angles morts aussi de cette
réforme c'est l'absence de prise en
compte des femmes notamment qui pour le
coup interrompent leur carrière
notamment pour des raisons de
parentalité il y a la question du
handicap aussi qui est très prégnante ou
en France on est vraiment pas bon sur le
taux d'emploi des personnes en situation
de handicap il y a évidemment la
question de l'âge avec les personnes les
plus âgées de nos seniors mais aussi les
personnes les plus jeunes ici je me suis
assez
surprise dans le bon sens de voir un
amendement qui évoque la dimension
systémique des discriminations au
travail puisque c'est assez rare que
vous ayez une vision d'ensemble je crois
que c'est vraiment un appel pour aller
plus loin notamment aussi pour écouter
les associations parce que à chaque fois
qu'on parle de discrimination il y a
toujours une importance assez cruciale à
travailler avec les premières personnes
concernées donc je nous encourage
vraiment à aller dans ce sens là et je
rappellerai enfin l'importance des
indicateurs de manière générale dans à
chaque fois que qu'on travaille en mode
projet et j'ose espérer que c'est le cas
de certains d'entre nous dans nos vies
professionnels passées les indicateurs
ils sont vraiment très importants pour
pouvoir avoir des objectifs avoir une
lisibilité sur ce qui se passe et
mesurer le progrès sinon on retombe
effectivement sur des coquilles vides
madame la rapporteur oui je voudrais
refaire un petit point sur ces
amendements parce qu'il en reste encore
beaucoup sur la précision de ces
indicateurs quand je donne un avis
défavorable forcément ça ne veut pas
dire que l'indicateur est mauvais le
critère que vous voulez rajouter est
mauvais ce qu'on dit et se comprend
comme partie c'est de dire qu'il faut
qu'il y ait des négociations de branches
pour être au plus près des entreprises
et qu'on ne veut pas donc rigidifier le
texte ça veut pas dire qu'on n'est pas
d'accord avec l'éventuelle mise en place
de ces critères
dans l'indicateur dans les index il va y
en avoir encore énormément où je vais
donner aussi des avis défavorables et où
pourtant ce sera probablement retenu par
les branches parce que parce que ce sont
des critères valables comme celui-là
mais voilà donc je voulais remettre ce
point que nous avons eu comme des bas
depuis hier puisque il y en a eu
beaucoup depuis hier il y en a encore
énormément à venir sur le même sujet
voilà donc ça reste un avis défavorable
ce qu'on dit c'est qu'il faut que ce
soit au plus proche du terrain par les
branches
très bien Madame Hugues vous maintenez
votre âme La Valette
présidente vous parliez mon chers
collègues effectivement vous faisiez le
parallèle avec l'index pour les
personnes porteuses de handicap mais mon
excellent collègue catho vous l'a dit
hier seulement 30% des entreprises
remplissent l'obligation des 6% des
travailleurs handicapés et 31% des
entreprises n'en a aucun alors même
qu'il y a des mesures coercitives alors
même qu'il y a des amendes à la clé et
on l'a vu aussi pour pour la parité mon
collègue vous l'a dit avant l'index
c'était 25% et après l'index et 27%.
donc on voit bien que la solution n'est
pas dans l'index la solution est dans un
changement de mentalité que ce soit pour
les personnes porteuses de handicap pour
la parité ou pour les seniors
très bien donc amendement maintenu par
ma collègue donc je le mets aux voix
avis défavorable de Madame la rapporteur
qui est pour
qui est contre
il est rejeté amendement suivant
monsieur aviranier oui merci madame la
Présidente pour appliquer l'index senior
aux administrations publiques mais
évidemment sans application de la menthe
très bien Madame la rapporteur
c'est satisfait parce que la loi du 6
août 2019 de transformation de la
fonction publique a créé l'obligation
pour l'administration d'élaborer chaque
année un rapport social qui lui est
alimenté par une base de données
sociales et qui répond à la demande donc
avis défavorable
très bien monsieur Petavy
c'est bien parce que dans tout ce que
vous évoquez ça c'est extraordinaire
parce qu'on fait toutes les choses à
l'envers alors on commence à parler des
retraites avant de parler donc de la
question de l'emploi parce que ça c'est
prévu je crois au printemps on se
retrouve avec peu de médecins du travail
avec peu de contrôleurs et on ne veut
surtout pas avoir un index exigeant
alors vous vous dites que ah non c'est
trop rigide il faut pas s'il faut pas là
bon ben on arrive avec cette coquille
totalement vide et un manque d'ambition
encore une fois alors on a répété ça
concerne les femmes ça concerne les
personnes en situation de handicap et là
la question des seniors et on voit que à
chaque fois ce à quoi ça conduit c'est
pas sérieux cette histoire là
très bien monsieur turquois
oui je voudrais réagir merci madame la
Présidente je voudrais réagir à
l'intervention qui vient d'être faite à
force de mettre des cadres dans tous les
sens on est monté à des taux de chômage
à des taux de chômage qui était
extrêmement élevés il y a d'abord la
première de nos
je parle tout confondu vous avez des
publics depuis 30 ans ont été maintenus
dans un chômage de longue durée on s'y
est attaqué et je crois avec un certain
nombre de résultats il y a beaucoup
d'imperfections il faut toujours
remettre le le
travail sur le sur le métier comment on
dit mais arrêtez de de vouloir
rigidifier les choses il faut mettre le
débat de l'emploi des seniors dans le
débat public ça c'est une vraie réalité
et après il faut laisser les branches
sans saisir parce que suivant les
branches il va y avoir des des
différences suivantes on voit bien
suivant les types de métiers l'approche
ne va pas être la même c'est déjà une
première étape mais la première étape
c'est de mettre les gens en emploi et
c'est ce qui n'a pas été fait depuis au
moins 30 ans donc je crois qu'on peut se
targuer de ce résultat qui est plutôt
dans le bon sens et ce qui montre que
parfois il faut des fois desserrer le
cadre pour pouvoir progresser
très bien monsieur le gars
oui monsieur turquois vous êtes
absolument formidable parce que vous
venez de de dire et de démontrer que les
chiffres en matière de lutte contre le
chômage sont effectivement très mauvais
alors une autre chose ah oui oui je vais
le démontrer vous allez voir c'est un
parable
ah oui oui non mais
très bien parfait non mais le déni le
déni tient lieu pour vous de vérité ça
c'est une méthode systématique en ce qui
vous concerne mais je vous rappelle
quand même que si on prend toutes les
catégories de chômeurs on arrive dans ce
pays à 6 millions et demi de chômeurs je
vous rappelle que le mois précédent le
nombre de radiations de Pôle emploi a
été exceptionnel je vous rappelle que le
nombre d'emplois précaires à
littéralement exploser sous le
quinquennat précédent et
particulièrement lors des années qui ont
précédé et quant au cadre rigide dont
vous venez de parler monsieur turquois
mais le gouverne ce gouvernement ainsi
que les gouvernements qui l'ont précédé
sous le quinquennat Macron le premier
quinquennat de Macron ce honte ont
entrepris de dynamiter absolument toutes
les règles ils l'ont fait en particulier
avec la loi Pénicaud qui a inversé dans
la continuité de la loi el khomri là
comment dire la hiérarchie des normes et
je suis désolé donc ne nous dites pas ne
nous dites pas qu'on rigidifie quoi que
ce soit il y a rien de rigidité il y a
rien de rigide il y a plus de cadres il
y a plus de cadres collectif vous les
avez fait implosés
très bien monsieur Viry
oui peut-être à ce stade ce stade de
discussion moi je rejoins un peu
l'observation qui a été faite et je l'ai
dit je croyais m'attendait marrant là ce
qui est dommage dans le cadre de nos
débats qui sont essentiels pour l'avenir
de notre pays et pour notre capacité à
verser des retraites à niveau le plus
adapté possible avec le plus de sécurité
c'est qu'on a décorrélé la le choix du
gouvernement était décoré les ce sujet à
la question globale d'un regard sur la
France sur le travail tant qu'on
produira pas en volume plus de plus de
valeur travail plus de cotisations on
aura effectivement comme seul ressources
que de toucher à l'âge légal ou
effectivement de trouver des solutions
qui bloquent le pays et qui rendent le
système le système délicat donc
effectivement il est probablement et je
l'ai dit il est probablement dommage que
le gouvernement n'est pas su
provoquer comme il sait le faire comme
parfois il donne le sentiment de le
faire à grand débat des états numéro sur
la question de la place du travail de la
valeur du travail du rapport des
Français au travail pour qu'on regarde
comment on peut lever de la cotisation
et donc du financement et là on en
arrive effectivement à des solutions qui
sont techniques qui sont imparfaites qui
sont insatisfaisantes qui sont
incompréhensibles et qui globalement
n'embarquent pas une majorité du pays
pour soutenir une réforme qui est
indispensable sur le fond
et bien madame
ibora
oui moi je voulais intervenir sur
ce qu'a dit notre collègue là sur le
chômage très rapidement parce que c'est
pas forcément
aujourd'hui ce qui nous préoccupe mais
je pense qu'en effet c'est lié ce qui
est sûr c'est que la gauche d'une
manière générale a toujours préféré des
chômeurs bien indemnisés que des
personnes en emploi c'est que c'est ce
que finalement on a vécu pendant des
années et ce à quoi on est on est arrivé
en effet avoir des résultats que
certains considèrent comme étant mauvais
mais je pense que la réalité et là que
d'autre part la loi toujours la loi la
loi qui pourrait changer les mentalités
je ne suis pas sûr je ne suis pas sûr et
je suis débuté je ne suis pas sûr que la
loi seule peut changer les mentalités et
que donc il faut alterner et le contrat
surtout dans dans notre société
aujourd'hui il faut alterner le contrat
et la loi et vous vous voulez imposer
idéologiquement
en montrant les entreprises comme étant
finalement des des organisations sur
lesquelles nous devons peser d'une
manière coercitive vous avez tort vous
avez absolument tort il faut les deux et
je crois par exemple quand je prends
l'exemple de la formation pour les pour
les pour les seniors il se peut que les
formations les seniors et très peu
d'appétence pour la formation c'est même
à mon avis ce nous allons être nous
allons trouver cette situation très
souvent laissons les entreprises et les
branches négocier en fonction de ce que
veulent aussi les personnes les seniors
parce qu'on en parle pas beaucoup des
seniors vraiment laissons les négocier
vérifions que les choses se fasse
correctement et finalement nous
arriverons je crois à des résultats qui
sont indispensables mais c'est pas parce
qu'on va l'imposer dans la loi que
demain ce sera mis en place
très très bien merci bien
non désolé monsieur Léo man je ne peux
pas vous donner la parole votre collègue
le Gâvre c'est exprimer là dessus très
bien et malgré tout je me permets une
remarque on ne peut pas dire que la
situation économique aujourd'hui est
catastrophique au regard des résultats
sur le chômage vous ne pouvez pas dire
ça les résultats sont là alors les
parfois ça vous arrange de nous sortir
effectivement certaines statistiques
mais là quand ça ne vous arrange pas
vous les balayez d'un revers de la main
vous ne pouvez pas dire ça à titre
personnel en Côte-d'Or le taux de
chômage étant de ça de 6%. ça c'est une
réalité et aujourd'hui les entreprises
ont énormément de difficultés à recruter
par manque effectivement de personnes
donc ne dites pas n'importe quoi non
plus désolé je le dis alors je mets aux
voix cet amendement qui a reçu un avis
défavorable qui est pour
qui est contre
il est rejeté monsieur Petavy vous avez
la parole ah ça faisait longtemps
compte tenu compte tenu du manque de
précision sur l'étendue et les modalités
des indicateurs les risques de
contournement du dispositif par les
entreprises sont réelles c'est
d'ailleurs ce que l'on a pu observer
dans le cas de l'index d'égalité
professionnelle ou les entreprises
peuvent ainsi sous évaluer les
inégalités pour grappiller quelques
points elles le font d'ailleurs dans la
quasi impunité puisque l'index d'égalité
professionnelle et lui aussi purement
déclaratif et n'a connu que très peu de
contrôle depuis sa mise en place l'index
senior est lui aussi proposé au nom de
l'information et de la transparence mais
la réalité c'est qu'en l'absence de
contrôle il y a un gros risque pour que
certaines entreprises peu scrupuleuses
jouent avec les méthodes de calcul pour
s'en tenir au minimum enfin que cette
index senior ne se cantonne pas lui
aussi à la simple formalité sans aucun
impact sur l'emploi des seniors il est
donc indispensable d'inclure à ce
dispositif un mécanisme de contrôle de
l'application du suivi des indicateurs
et des mesures mises en place merci bien
Madame la rapporteur
avis défavorable très bien monsieur Léo
man
oui c'est pour continuer cette excellent
débat sur le chômage et le travail vous
nous avez dit tout à l'heure madame
ibaurin vous préférez des chômeurs bien
indemnisés plutôt que des gens au
travail bah non c'est pas ça vous avez
pas compris nous on préfère des gens au
travail bien payés c'est-à-dire avec des
bons salaires parce que des bons
salaires ça fait quoi et ben ça fait
plus de cotisations sociales et ça
permet de financer le système de
retraite donc premier point il faut des
gens au travail et qui ont un salaire
digne parce que ça permet de financer le
système de retraite mais ensuite quand
les gens perdent leur emploi et la
plupart du temps quand les gens perdent
leur emploi c'est pas un choix ça peut
être qu'une entreprise ferme ça peut
être un certain nombre de choses et
notamment des délocalisations
d'entreprises sur lesquelles le
gouvernement fait à peu près rien et qui
provoque donc des fermetures de boîtes
et des pertes d'emploi bon bah qu'est-ce
qu'on veut dans ce cas là on veut que
les chômeurs soient bien indemnisés ça
c'est vrai mais pourquoi parce que ça
permet de mettre en place un rapport de
force avec le patronat qui fait que les
gens qui sont au chômage peuvent avoir
le choix de l'emploi dans lequel ils
vont et de l'exigence d'une certaine
rémunération vous ce que vous voulez
finalement c'est l'inverse ces données
un espèce de comment dire d'armée de
réserve pour le patronat qui soit sous
un démunisé pour lui permettre de
proposer des salaires très bas avec des
métiers qui sont très difficiles et il y
a quelque part un lien très direct entre
la réforme de la retraite que vous
voulez faire en augmentant l'âge de
départ à la retraite et la réforme de
l'assurance chômage que vous avez faite
pour diminuer l'indemnisation des
chômeurs parce que qu'est-ce que vous
voulez en réalité vous ne voulez pas
l'emploi des seniors vous voulez mettre
des personnes qui sont assez âgées au
chômage dans certains cas sous rémunérés
pour être obligé d'accepter des emplois
qui sont en dessous de leur niveau de
compétence voilà ce que vous êtes en
train de faire et voilà la raison pour
laquelle vous nous trouvez en travers de
votre chemin et voilà la raison pour
laquelle de nombreuses personnes
aujourd'hui arrêtent le travail ça
s'appelle la grève pour vous faire
retirer votre projet de loi
très bien monsieur turquois
alors là on a une vision hallucinante du
travail
dans mon territoire dans mon territoire
qui est industriel le taux de chômage il
est autour de 5%. et comme
et comme je vous ai pas interrompu et
comme le vrai demande en emploi il y a
des rémunérations qui sont il y a des
rémunérations qui sont largement
augmentées parce que les entrepreneurs
cherchent des compétences et donc ça
fait un vrai appel d'air sur y compris
des emplois seniors des gens qui qui
sont gardés en entreprise parce qu'ils
ont une vraie compétence donc
développons l'offre d'emploi quand on
développe l'offre d'emploi il y a une
forme d'appel d'air sur sur ceux qui ont
une compétence une aptitude au travail
qui fait que les rémunérations
augmentent on peut le constater sur des
territoires où le taux de chômage est
faible arrêtons d'avoir une vision
étriquée du travail comme vous pouvez le
voir
très bien Monsieur Paul Christophe
oui quelque part je plains pour mon
collègue parce que voir les choses en
noir en permanence comme ça je demande
comment doit être sa vie cela dit quand
il nous interpelle sur les
délocalisations quand on interprète de
la question quand je vous écoute et vous
croyez qu'un investisseur il avait envie
d'investir en France vous croyez qu'il
aura pas envie de partir en courant avec
les entreprises qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé d'ailleurs ces dernières années à
chaque fois qu'on a taxé surtaxé et bien
les investisseurs ont fait le pays tout
simplement donc votre vision finalement
vous c'est la destruction massive
d'emplois je suis pas sûr que ça vienne
contribuer au maintien des seigneurs de
l'emploi très sincèrement deuxièmement
deuxièmement je suis désolé mais
regardez ce qui se passe dans notre pays
en termes de taux de chômage ça vous
irrite je le comprends mais nous sommes
en pénurie d'emploi dans nombre de
secteurs et vous croyez du coup on n'a
pas envie de garder nos seniors
on n'a pas envie de capitaliser
justement sur leur expérience et leurs
compétences et bien si je suis désolé de
vous l'apprendre dans ce cas là donc je
vous invite à réviser un petit peu votre
doctrine parce qu'elle est profondément
en décalage avec la société sur ces deux
là
très bien monsieur alosé
oui un peu je trouve que le peu de
considération que certains collègues ont
pour leurs collègues précisément au
motifs qui sont de la majorité qui
seraient du côté du président des riches
et je ne sais quoi on entend que cette
ritournelle depuis des mois et des mois
mais quel manque de considération pour
vos collègues
est-ce que vous savez que depuis le
travail que l'on mène le nombre
d'emplois en CDI augmente en permanence
on est passé de 48% à 52% de CDI donc on
veut que les gens du travail on veut que
les gens aient un emplois stable plus il
y aura de gens au travail plus la
pression sur les salaires augmentera et
plus leur salaire augmenteront plus vous
aurez déjà au chômage plus les salaires
baisseront vous êtes complètement à
l'envers mais complètement à côté de ce
qu'il faut pour pour nos concitoyens
donc je demande un peu plus de
considération franchement un peu plus de
considération pour vos collègues on veut
tous ici le bien de nos concitoyens vous
sans doute je l'espère tous y compris à
l'extrême droite je pense nous aussi
alors un peu de respect pour nous s'il
vous plaît
très bien
[Musique]
Madame sebahi non parce que il y a
Monsieur Peytavi qui va s'exprimer qui a
demandé la parole et Madame Garin c'est
déjà exprimé également
ah d'accord
très bien alors madame c'est Bailly vous
avez la parole et ensuite monsieur
Peytavi merci merci beaucoup alors c'est
très intéressant de vous entendre pour
les collègues de la majorité parce que
vous nous parlez du travail et du
chômage et en réalité non je vous parle
de la question des salaires parce
qu'aujourd'hui en fait vous faites
travailler les gens certes mais pour des
salaires de misère donc c'est aussi la
réalité de ce que vivent les gens et
puis vous nous parlez du chômage et du
taux de chômage soit disant qu'il aurait
baissé dans plusieurs régions pourquoi
vous ne parlez pas des gens qui ont été
radiés et qui ont été jetés dans les SAS
de pauvreté en fait depuis les
différentes réformes et depuis ce que
vous avez construit sous le quinquennat
précédent donc donner la réalité des
chiffres effectivement nous on n'est pas
du tout ennuyé on n'est pas ennuyé non
le RSA ne baisse pas vous parler du
travail de seniors excusez-moi vous
parler du travail des seniors alors moi
je vais vous donner un chiffre depuis
qu'on est passé de l'âge de la retraite
de 60 à 62 ans en 10 ans c'est 157% de
seniors qui sont passés au RSA vous avez
créé un sas de pauvreté que vous allez
doubler en passant de 62 à 64 ans c'est
ça la réalité des chiffres donc arrêtez
de nous faire la leçon au contraire
écouter ce qu'on vous dit parce que je
pense effectivement que beaucoup sont
sincères et qu'on veut améliorer les
choses mais ce que vous proposez
aujourd'hui ne va pas dans le bon sens
et on n'arrête pas de vous le répéter
très bien
il s'avère que dans mon département en
Côte-d'Or j'ai le président de l'ADF
monsieur tout le monde connaît Monsieur
François Sauvadet je suis désolé le
nombre de bénéficiaires du RSA à diminué
vous pouvez pas dire le contraire ce
sont des gens qui ont rebondi
professionnelnellement il a rebondi
pourra effectivement vous le confirmer
très bien alors Monsieur
Philippe Vigier très bien
vous venez de dire quelque chose
d'important sur le nombre d'électriciens
du RSA je vous rappelle chers collègues
de la nuit Pesse et il vous ferait
passer le document que département par
département le nom des bénéficiaires du
RSA nous était transmis vous en souvenez
probablement dans la discussion du
projet de loi de finances 2023 et
lorsque ce document nous a été donné
chacun a pu constater qu'il y avait que
deux seuls départements où il y a eu une
augmentation dans tous les autres il y
avait une diminution ne dites pas
n'importe quoi c'est la vérité et bien
moi je prends pas des valeurs je vous ai
écouté la moindre des choses est-ce que
vous voulez bien m'écouter
je demande juste de m'écouter je prends
l'engagement madame la Présidente
puisque ce document nous avait été donné
par Gabriel Attal Auban quand le
transmettre à nos collègues ne répandons
pas des fake news ça n'apporte rien de
dire des contre-vérités
[Musique]
à l'ensemble des députés très bien donc
je mets aux voix donc c'est un
amendement qui a reçu un avis
défavorable qui est pour
qui est contre il est rejeté amendement
suivant monsieur Bazin merci madame la
Présidente un rapporteur mes chers
collègues je vous pose par cet
amendement de préciser après la Linéa 8
que le présent article
qu'à la population dite administrative
dans le cas des structures sportives
professionnelles vous allez me dire ça
concerne peu de clubs on a la chance
d'en avoir en France l'indique l'index
ne s'appliquerait pas aux sportif joueur
et entraîneur en effet il faut qu'on
puisse prendre en compte les
particularités suivantes du sport
professionnel les contacts de travail
sont dans le sport professionnel des
contrats à durée déterminée spécifique
les carrières sportives professionnelles
sont particulièrement courtes en moyenne
inférieure à 7 ans et pouvant également
être stoppé brutalement suite à une
blessure au regard de l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite les sportifs
joueurs et entraîneurs ne peuvent pas
tous bénéficier d'un reclassement sur
les postes administratifs internes
je pense que c'est important alors qu'on
a des équipes professionnelles avec des
centres de formation avec des équipes
l'insuline et féminine qui se développe
et on voit bien qu'il y a le souci de la
professionnalisation notamment au niveau
des des jeunes et on voit bien si on
regarde un peu la structure de la
plupart de nos clubs professionnels par
exemple de Ligue 1 ils se situent entre
250 et 500 salariés donc on voit bien
qu'il y a un sujet particulier à prendre
en compte et à amender dans cet article
très bien Madame la rapporteur vous avez
raison monsieur Bazin mais c'est
justement pour cette raison qu'il faut
laisser les branches décider parce que
dans les entreprises de sport
effectivement il y aura un sens qui sera
différent que dans d'autres entreprises
donc je suis d'accord avec vous sur le
fond mais encore une fois laissons les
branches elles vont le elles vont le
décrire dans leur critères pour les
entreprises qui sont concernées sur le
monde sportif
très bien alors Monsieur leoman puis
madame Rousseau
oui je vais répondre quand même à
plusieurs choses qui ont été dites qui
me semble assez inexactes on me dit
collèguemoins vous avez une vision
étriquée du monde du travail mais en
fait en réalité je partage un certain
nombre de choses que vous avez dit avant
c'est-à-dire vous dites ben le but c'est
de créer de l'emploi pour faire en sorte
que il y a un taux de chômage qui
diminue la baisse du taux de chômage
provoque une pression à la hausse sur
les salaires je suis d'accord avec vous
à 100% sur ça je vous dis pas autre
chose je ne vous dis pas autre chose et
précisément je suis en train de vous
dire aussi que quand on indemnise mieux
les chômeurs la pression sur les
salaires est également plus importante
maintenant autre chose collègues vous
nous dites ah là là brillant nous sommes
passés de 48 à 52% de CDI formidable on
devrait s'aplatir à genoux devant vous
avec des genouillères pour éviter la
pénibilité quand même et se féliciter de
votre génie et de votre brio enfin nous
sommes ici des législateurs nous pouvons
imposer des choses aux entreprises et ce
que c'est ce que proposait précisément
de faire Jean-Luc Mélenchon avec son
programme on proposait qu'il y ait pas
plus de 10 % de CDD dans les grandes
entreprises et pas plus de 5 dans les
petites non l'inverse pas plus de 10
dans les petites et pas plus de 5 dans
les grandes donc si nous le voulions
chers collègues nous pourrions imposer
pas demandé pas souhaité par faire des
courbettes imposer aux entreprises de
faire en sorte d'avoir des emplois et
enfin on dirait qu'il y a que le privé
dans ce pays enfin c'est dingue et les
fonctionnaires alors ça n'existe pas et
l'État c'est pas un employeur et les
collectivités territoriales c'est pas
des employeurs enfin voilà la réforme
des retraites même et le corps nous le
dit vient en partie du fait ce que vous
êtes en train de faire vous là en ce
moment ça vient en partie du fait que 1
vous avez diminué l'embauche du nombre
de fonctionnaires et que deux vous avez
fait stagner leur salaire arrêtez de
nous prendre pour des abrutis au bout
d'un moment on est capable de lire les
rapports comme vous sauf que on en tient
pas la même lecture soyez capable de
reconnaître qu'il y a ici des gens qui
sont tout aussi bosseurs que vous mais
qu'on est désaccords fondamentaux sur la
manière de gérer le pays nous voulons
nous la force à la loi aux entreprises
très bien Madame Rousseau
oui je fais une petite insertion avant
de parler du fond de cette amendement
mais pour dire que le 26 janvier 2023 le
monde commençait un article par cette
phrase l'augmentation des radiations de
Pôle Emploi pourrait-elle expliqué la
forte baisse du nombre de deux monteurs
d'emploi enregistrés au quatrième
trimestre 2022 et en fait elle est la
question c'est-à-dire qu'évidemment on
peut faire baisser les chiffres du
chômage en augmentant les radiations on
peut aussi faire baisser les chiffres du
RSA par le non recours et je rappelle
que le taux de non recours du RSA par
trimestre et de 34% c'est à dire qu'il y
a une personne sur trois et vous ne
devez vraiment il y a une personne sur
trois qui a le droit au RSA qui n'y
recourt pas et c'est une honte pour
notre pays et c'est une honte pour nos
droits sociaux donc
la baisse du nombre de RSA n'a rien ne
dit rien en fait de la réalité de la
précarité de votre population et vous
devriez la regarder différemment sur la
carrière des sportifs puisque tel est
l'amendements que dont nous discutons
aujourd'hui et bien je m'interroge moi
que va faire Mbappe après 50 ans
et que va-t-il faire je sais pas si je
sais pas si je ne sais pas si je ne sais
pas si Emmanuel Macron au moment où il
faisait des papouilles à Mbappe lui a
parlé de sa carrière et de sa carrière
quand il serait senior et en
l'occurrence oui la carrière des
sportifs et les vieillissement des
sportifs est un sujet au-delà de la
plaisanterie il est un réel sujet
Comment on réinsère les personnes qui
par ailleurs on décore qui parfois sont
abîmés blessés par une pratique sportive
intensive que fait-on de ces sportifs
seniors et bah c'est un sujet et donc il
faut les intégrer au contraire dans
l'index
très bien monsieur Ferracci
oui merci madame la Présidente quelques
éléments de réponse à ce qui vient
d'être dit et puis une petite remarque
sur l'amendement de notre collègue Bazin
si on a deux définitions du taux de
chômage ou plutôt deux définitions du
chômage c'est précisément pour ne pas
avoir à commenter les effets et bien des
inscriptions administratives de la DFM
de Pôle emploi il y a une définition qui
s'appelle celle du Bureau international
du travail qui n'est absolument pas
soumise aux questions de radiation et
qui montre que le taux de chômage baisse
donc je vous invite à vous référer à
cette définition là qui permet les
comparaisons internationales et qui
montrent que depuis le début du
quinquennat taux de chômage est passé de
9,5 à 7,3% et les radiations ils sont
absolument pour rien ça c'est le premier
point deuxième point on a parlé de la
qualité de l'emploi et c'est un sujet
auquel nous sommes tous très attachés je
veux compléter les propos tout à fait
juste de mon collègue Eric à lozet pour
dire qu'en 2022 nous avons battu le
record du nombre d'embauches en CDI avec
5,1 millions d'embauches en CDI c'est un
record absolu c'est encore absolu et
c'est la preuve que on peut accroître
l'emploi sans sacrifier la qualité de
l'emploi et c'est bien la philosophie de
notre action quand vous évoquez
accessoirement s'agissant de la DFM que
il y a 6 millions de chômeurs vous
négligez le fait que il y en a une
grande partie qui travaille dans les
catégories B et C et qui donc de ce
point de vue ne sont pas dans la même
situation que les autres enfin juste une
petite remarque sur l'amendement de
notre collègue Bazin
évidemment ça peut apparaître comme une
démarche de bon sens que de se dire que
les sportifs professionnels n'ont pas
priori par la même pas la même situation
que les autres se dire quand même que
les sportifs professionnels
représentent j'ai lu le le chiffre qui
est donné par la branche des clubs
sportifs professionnels seulement 7000
personnes dans toute la France qu'en
réalité l'effectif des clubs sportifs
est composé très largement et bien des
personnels d'accompagnement des
personnels administrat de telle sorte
qu'il n'est pas certain de mon point de
vue que l'index joue un grand rôle où
les pénalistes très fortement ce que je
voulais dire très bien monsieur
Delaporte oui merci je suis d'accord
avec le dernier élément de mon collègue
ferrachi une fois n'est pas Coutu sur
par ailleurs la nécessité de penser à la
reconversion des sportifs professionnels
mais moi je voudrais d'abord répondre à
mon collègue Vigier sur
en termes de fake news RSA parce que si
on constate effectivement une baisse de
recours au RSA en 2021 il y a plusieurs
explications la première c'est que on
sort des années de crise covid avec un
approfond majeur de la population
française si on regarde des raisons pour
lesquelles les gens sortent du RSA parce
que c'est ça qu'il faut regarder les
sorties pour radiation administratives
n'ont jamais été aussi élevés en 2022
qu'auparavant
donc ça c'est le premier élément c'est
de la radiation administrative des
sorties pour défaut d'actualisation qui
n'ont jamais été aussi importantes et
par ailleurs qu'est-ce qui n'a jamais
été aussi faible c'est les sorties pour
reprise d'emploi c'est à dire qu'on ne
sort pas du RSA parce qu'on a retrouvé
du travail mais parce que soit on a été
radié soit on a un problème
administratif donc vous voyez il faut
regarder aussi à quoi sont du ces
chiffres et un peu le détail de tout ça
parce que si on regarde d'autres
éléments ce qui nous intéresse c'est la
pauvreté si on regarde une source que
j'espère personne n'ira contestée qui
est le rapport sur l'état de la pauvreté
en France du Secours Catholique la part
des personnes qui sont mis en emploi ni
en formation ni au chômage augmente
constamment au point de représenter 60%
des personnes rencontrées en 2021 donc
la priorité des priorités si on veut
s'attaquer à la question de la pauvreté
en France c'est de s'attaquer à ceux qui
sont venus en emploi ni en formation ni
au chômage et qui devrait constituer
l'essentiel de nos efforts donc voilà un
peu de tentative de décryptage de vos
fake news
très bien Madame La Valette madame la
Présidente merci Monsieur Ferracci je
sais pas quand je vous écoute je suis un
peu inquiète on a l'impression que vous
n'avez pas la mesure du manque de
productivité des emplois qui sont créés
et encore une fois je veux bien
comprendre que la productivité soit la
grande absente de cette réforme des
retraites mais madame le Président aussi
vous vous gargarisez des emplois qui
sont créés mais en fait on a besoin
d'emploi à haute valeur ajoutée les
emplois qui sont créés depuis 5 ans les
emplois sous l'air sous l'air Macron on
arrive à une société
ubérisée 62% des entreprises qui ont été
créées sont des TPE et on sait très bien
que c'est une ubérisation de la société
et vous n'avez vous avez l'air de ne pas
en prendre conscience et je pense
qu'encore une fois je reprends mes
propres préliminaires on dans le
vide tant qu'on a pas compris qu'il
fallait parler de productivité et de
natalité ressemblent vous n'avez la
mesure ni de l'un ni de l'autre
très bien Monsieur Paul Christophe
oui merci ma président puisque je
voudrais revenir sur sur les propos
tenus outils du RSA pour semblant on
prendra un exemple assez concret sur du
département du Nord puisque avec
Charlotte Le Coq nous
et Christine Decotte qui est présente
également c'est pour vous dire que voilà
nous sommes passés de 115000 à
locataires à 93000 locataires au moins
de 6 ans et madame la Présidente c'est
tout simplement pas parce que
contrairement à ce que je viens
d'entendre de manière assez honteuse
nous avons encouragé nos recours tout
simplement parce que nous avons mis en
place des mesures de proximité avec les
allocateurs du RSA pour les accompagner
vers le retour à l'emploi et que ces
grandes cette grande évolution est dû
justement au retour à l'emploi et je
vous invite à venir à vous rapprocher
les services du département je pense que
les travailleurs sociaux mobilisés sur
cette opération était particulièrement à
mon avis écorchée de vous entendre dire
qu'ils encouragent à nos recours alors
qu'ils sont visés chaque jour pour
accompagner les uns et les autres vers
de la formation parfois sur du temps
long d'ailleurs parce que une formation
ce n'est pas forcément et bien acquis
sur un temps relativement court et nous
nous mettons en adéquation avec les
besoins également nos territoires et
donc nous accompagnons ces allocataires
vers plus de grâce à l'emploi et c'est
ça qui nous mobilise chaque jour
très bien monsieur Bazin
merci madame la Présidente
hier vous vous plaisantiez en disant
qu'en tant que professeur vous mettiez
parfois hors sujet hors sujets le débat
est passionnant sur la question du RSA
mais ça s'éloigne un peu de l'amendement
que je vous proposais qui était de
pouvoir adapter
aux structures sportives
professionnelles
moi je j'entends la remarque de la
rapporteur qui renvoie à une négociation
de branche alors c'est vrai que la
branche du du sport on a cinq
conventions à ma connaissance spécifique
au sport professionnel c'est vrai que ça
ne concerne que 7000 personnes mais il y
a un mouvement de professionnalisation
je pense notamment aux équipes féminines
qui qui sont en train de se développer
avec des enjeux et ces carrières des
sportifs on le sait bien ça permet aussi
parfois quand tout le monde n'aspire pas
forcément enfin n'aura pas la chance
d'être en équipe de France ou d'avoir
voilà mais pour pouvoir accompagner pour
pouvoir aider il y a un vrai enjeu par
rapport à cet âge là sachant que on ne
fera pas sportif professionnel toute sa
vie et et moi je suis choqué par les
propos de de Madame Rousseau moi j'ai un
respect et pour le talent de Kylian
Mbappé notre pays a de la chance d'avoir
un tel joueur mais autour de lui il y a
surtout des coéquipiers et parfois qui
me connaîtront pas tous le haut niveau
et dans un cas dans un club
professionnel avec un effectif d'une
trentaine de joueurs et autant de
joueuses et parfois des jeunes contrats
dans les centres de formation en fait ça
peut biaiser l'index bien sûr tout le
monde n'est pas concerné mais forcément
quand on a un tel volume de 60 voire
plus dans une structure qui fait
peut-être 310 salariés j'ai regardé
l'Olympique Lyonnais l'Olympique de
Marseille et on a un certain nombre de
clubs en fait ils sont tous entre 249 et
500 salariés et quand on additionne la
recherche de professionnalisation
d'équipes féminine il y a un enjeu
là-dessus moi aux a entendu je vais
retirer en vue de la séance pour
vérifier que que l'impact d'un accord de
branche permettra de prendre en compte
c'est spécificités et d'intégrer ces
inquiétudes légitimes de manière à ce
qu'on ne pénalise pas les structures
professionnelles sportives et notamment
celle qui cherche à professionnaliser
les équipes féminines très bien donc
amendement retirer mais monsieur Vigier
vous voulez vous vouliez rebondir
un président merci madame la Présidente
je voulais rebondir parce que tout à
l'heure nos collègues
insoumis qui nous disaient qu'on a fait
un véritable casse sociale en diminuant
le nom des fonctionnaires
donc je l'invite simplement à regarder
les statistiques que je viens de
retrouver et par rapport à 97 chers
collègues quand la population française
mais je peux terminer ma phrase sans que
tout de suite l'indignation vous gagne
par rapport à 97 la population française
elle a augmenté de 13%
le nom des fonctionnaires il a augmenté
de
22%. et dans cette augmentation la 36%
dans la fonction publique hospitalière
34%
34% dans la fonction publique
territoriale et 13% dans la fonction
publique des tas le seul quinquennat sur
lequel il y a eu une augmentation
limitée à 14000 c'est celui de Nicolas
Sarkozy donc voyez ne dites pas qu'il y
a moins de fonctionnaires qu'il n'y en
avait 22 ans plus tard avec une
augmentation de la population uniquement
de 13%, le nombre des fonctionnaires
augmentés de 23%, je pense que la
démonstration suffit pour dire qu'une
fois de plus vous avez essayé de nous
emmener sur un chemin qui n'était pas le
bon très bien Madame la rapporteur
je vous donne le micro oui merci madame
la Présidente je voudrais répondre aux
collègues Léo Man et pour faire plaisir
à Monsieur Bazin on n'est pas hors sujet
puisqu'il s'agit de la réforme des
retraites et du rapport du corps vous
parliez des fonctionnaires mais ça bien
été pris en compte par le rapport du
corps l'augmentation du point d'indice
des fonctionnaires et donc de la des
salaires c'est la page 48 du rapport
très bien donc nous allons passer à deux
amendements qui peuvent être mis en
discussion commune monsieur Vigier c'est
Monsieur Cyril Lisa civil pas de
problème merci à présent on défendra ces
deux amendements ensemble tous ici de
manière unanime nous souhaitons nous
soutenir l'emploi des seniors car même
après 50 ans un travail permet aux
salariés d'avoir un revenu une part
dépendre d'une allocation chômage mais
aussi parce que le travail et l'activité
permet au Seigneur de conserver un rôle
social d'apporter leur contribution à
nos sociétés je suis content que notre
que nos collègues n'aupaissent
souhaitent comme nous
que les seigneurs puissent travailler
car travailler est une notion qui est
noble non messieurs d'opposition vous
n'êtes pas les seuls à vouloir améliorer
c'est index des seniors un Death qui
vous est qualifié parfois de rideau de
fumée de décoration de fumisterie
WhatsApp le groupe modem vous propose
d'adopter pour les entreprises qui
gardent ou embauche enseignants une
mesure de bonus malus de majoration de
minoration des cotisations sociales des
employeurs et ceci grâce au dialogue
social et je laisse mon collègue Crozier
poursuivre la présentation de cette
amendement
merci madame la Présidente
figurez-vous mes chers collègues seuls
33% des 60 63 ans sont en emploi en
France
c'est 45% dans l'Union européenne c'est
70% en Suède
est-ce que nous pouvons nous satisfaire
de ces chiffres alors évidemment non
nous nous privons d'une richesse
exceptionnelle au sein de nos
entreprises nous priverons la
transmission des compétences nous
privons la transmission de l'expérience
les députés du groupe démocrate sont
convaincus que la question de l'emploi
des seniors est au cœur de la réforme
nous sommes convaincus de la nécessité
d'un dispositif d'incitation à
l'embauche et au maintien des seniors en
entreprise c'est la raison pour laquelle
mes chers collègues nous proposons de
compléter l'index seniors par un système
de Banus de bonus malus sur les
cotisations des entreprises valorisant
les entreprises vertueuses et incitant
les autres à s'engager dans une démarche
positive c'est la nous avons confiance
au dialogue social nous y sommes
attachés aussi la partie
de donner les latitudes aux partenaires
sociaux dans définir les modalités au
plus près du terrain dans le cadre d'un
accord national interprofessionnel d'ici
le premier janvier 2024 très bien Madame
la rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente je suis
ennuyée sur le la forme de votre
amendement parce que vous vous décrivez
la notion de performance qui a ce stade
pas défini pour l'index senior et
d'autre part vous les moduler les
cotisations de la branche sur la branche
ATMP qui sont déjà modelés en fonction
de la du taux de sinistralité dans
l'entreprise ça serait donc totalement
illisible et incompréhensible ces
cotisations soient à nouveau modules sur
un sur un fondement qui en plus n'est
pas clair puisqu'il n'est pas défini
donc c'est un avis défavorable sur votre
amendement vos amendements très bien
monsieur de la porte
le mérite de ces amendements c'est de
permettre d'armer
un index qui pour l'instant était
singulièrement dépourvu de tout pouvoir
plus que informatique donc là on va
au-delà de l'incitation on commence à
flirter non pas avec la coercition mais
avec un dispositif de bonus malus qui
donne des conséquences opérationnelles à
la qualité de l'emploi des seniors et
donc moi je souscris pleinement à la
philosophie puisque c'est ce qu'on
essaye de faire depuis le début c'est
être au-delà de la pétition de principe
d'avoir un index et seniors qui sert
réellement à quelque chose puisque il
permettrait d'indiquer
la réalité de la qualité de l'emploi des
signaux alors
ça entre en résonance à ce que j'ai avec
ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure au tout
début
j'ai cru comprendre que le Bureau
Exécutif pardon d'y reparler encore des
renaissances hier à caresser l'idée
d'avoir une démarche un peu plus
coercitive et envisager y compris cette
logique de modulation des cotisations en
fonction de l'index il me semble aussi
que j'ai vu cette proposition
formulée par Françoise slein le patron
de la Confédération des petites et
moyennes entreprises en disant si on a
cette modulation avec un système de
bonus malus alors on aura quelque chose
d'un peu plus opérationnel donc nous on
est tout à fait d'accord avec l'esprit
et même la lettre mais on pourrait y
compris aller plus loin d'ailleurs vous
venez de le dire Madame la rapporteur et
j'ai pas comment vous ferez si en séance
vous avez un amendement venant de votre
groupe ou du gouvernement qui muscle un
petit peu l'index senior on verra mais
la modulation des cotisations ATMP on
pourrait aussi et peut-être le
sous-amender ici ou en séance le faire
sur la modulation des cotisations
assurance vieillesse
parce que je pense que c'est exactement
le même le même esprit donc nous cet
amendement nous va très bien voilà
très bien monsieur Bazin
oui merci
le côté vertueux de pouvoir
moduler à la baisse des cotisations
sociales
de manière à pouvoir encourager
l'emploi des séniors on est persuadé
qu'il faut un choc d'attractivité
fiscal pour permettre vraiment au-delà
de l'index parce que je pense que
l'index en lui-même ne va pas créer les
conditions de manière à vraiment
améliorer le taux d'emploi
or il y a plein de questions qui se
posent parce que l'index va être publié
chaque année est-ce que ça veut dire que
pour l'année suivante on a le droit à un
allègement ou un amendement or en
matière de de cotisation on l'assiette
ne dépend pas forcément d'un index mais
plutôt pour le coup
de ceux qui travaillent en cours d'année
parce que c'est un côté de perception
qui qui pose souci dans la mise en œuvre
c'est une question technique la deuxième
c'est par rapport à la modulation de la
modulation ça a été évoqué tout à
l'heure il faudrait pas qu'on en arrive
comme sur le coco pour les collectivités
locales au final finalement la
péréquation de la péricquation annule la
péricquation initiale entre la
sinistrelosité et le
l'incitation à l'embauche des seniors
parce qu'il pourra avoir un effet
contre-intuitif dans les faits donc moi
je me demande s'il faudrait pas plutôt
aller sur une baisse des charges sur
l'emploi des seniors direct et réel que
liée à un index dont on ne sait pas s'il
survivra à ce texte puisqu'à priori il y
en a un certain nombre qui pensent que
c'est index est inutile donc faisons
peut-être l'hypothèse d'abandonner
l'index et travailler sur l'amélioration
de l'embauche des seniors
très bien
Madame ozone
alors
voilà un exemple qui montre que un
indicateur sur la façon dont les seniors
sont employés dans quelles conditions
donc sur des conditions précises se
réutilisent d'ailleurs on peut partir
d'un constat sur lequel on va être
d'accord le fait que faire travailler
les gens plus longtemps va coûter parce
que l'usure des corps se paye faire
travailler un couvreur qui tombe du toit
et parfois garde des séquelles à vie ça
se paye faire travailler une aide à
domicile qui doit porter des gens à bout
de bras qui peut se blesser ça se paye
faire de la mise en rayon à 10 cm du sol
se briser le dos parfois les poignets ça
se paye d'ailleurs c'est un rapport de
l'INRS qui dit que les quelques études
qui sont disponibles montrent que les
travailleurs plus âgés ont moins
d'accidents que les jeunes mais par
contre ces accidents là souvent sont
plus graves et d'ailleurs les accidents
chez les seniors entraînent des
séquelles plus fréquentes 14 % des
accidents chez les 50 59 ans
occasion une incapacité permanente
contre 2% chez les moins de 20 ans donc
ça c'est des choses qui va falloir
prendre en compte effectivement mais
alors
pourquoi envisager de minorer les
cotisations sociales
majorée d'accord puisque les séquelles
sont plus importantes et vous êtes les
premiers à déplorer le fait qu'il manque
12 milliards d'euros donc ne commencez
pas à chercher ou encore faire des
économies littéralement sur le dos des
travailleuses et des travailleurs là
dessus on ne se retrouvera pas
très bien Madame Rousseau
derrière là oui merci madame la
Présidente en fait il existe déjà un
certain nombre d'aides et de soutien à
l'emploi des seniors il y a les détails
c'est des seniors il y a le CDI
inclusion il y a le parcours emploi
compétences et en fait aucun de ces
dispositifs pour l'instant donner les
résultats escomptés pourquoi parce qu'en
fait quelque chose n'est toujours pas
à qui dans le monde professionnel c'est
les conditions de travail et l'évolution
de de la dureté des des métiers et
l'intensification de ces métiers je
rappelle que depuis maintenant 20 ans
nous avons connu une intensification
conséquente des métiers des contraintes
des pressions des stress des risques
psychosociaux des maladies
professionnelles des risques de de
troubles musculo-squelettiques comme peu
de pays en Europe l'ont connu comme peu
de pays en Europe pour connu et en fait
la question fondamentale ça n'est pas
tant une énième exonération de
cotisation sociale que quels
accompagnements fait-on pour que les
personnes soit
bien en bonne santé et j'ajoute heureuse
au travail jusqu'à
jusque jusqu'à l'attente de l'âge senior
et en fait cette question là n'est pas
posée c'est-à-dire qu'on pose la
question uniquement sous l'angle des
contraintes c'est-à-dire que il y a une
obligation à travailler pour les seniors
en regard par exemple de la réforme du
chômage qui a été adopté bien contre
notre gré dans cette assemblée il y a
quelques mois qui dit que puisque il y a
un taux de chômage important chez les
seniors on va diminuer la durée
d'indemnisation de sorte que soit il se
retrouve dans cette fameuse trappe pas
précarité soit ils sont obligés de
reprendre un travail quel que soit les
conditions physiques ou morales dans
lesquelles ils sont je rappelle par
exemple aussi que les dispositifs qui
ont déjà existants comprennent la
question de seniors jusqu'à 45 depuis 45
ans c'est-à-dire que ce sur quoi vous
avez beaucoup ri hier qui était de
définir la question des seniors on n'est
pas anecdotique en réalité à quel âge on
commence à être seniors et donc oui pour
augmenter les cotisations sociales des
entreprises qui ne respecteraient pas
l'emploi des des seniors aucun problème
avec ça mais pourquoi encore une fois la
diminuer encore une fois madame
parmentier
merci madame la Présidente
[Musique]
à la fois on
sent qu'il y a peut-être une piste à
creuser mais en même temps qui n'est pas
du tout mur à aujourd'hui parce que on
manque quand même un peu de données
aussi sur les effets de bord que
pourrait avoir cette cette notion un peu
de bonus malus et aussi les impacts
peut-être sur d'autres publics on veut
aussi
soutenir dans leur accès à l'emploi donc
je crois que déjà sur le fond pour moi
c'est encore à mûrir et là sur la
proposition qui nous est faite
d'utiliser la branche ATMP pour
matérialiser ce bonus manus là on crée
véritablement une usine à gaz parce que
aujourd'hui la branche ATMP elle prévoit
justement des modèles enfin des des
modalités de bonus malus liées à la
sinistralité et donc il faut que ça
reste assez lisible pour encourager les
employeurs à aller vers plus de
prévention qui seront utiles de façon à
tous les salariés et aussi au seniors là
si on ajoute un nouveau modèle de bonus
malus on rend les choses extrêmement
vraiment compliqué donc ça ne semble pas
être la bonne voie en tout cas pour
encourager à l'emploi des seniors et
bien monsieur Müller
merci madame la Présidente donc
l'adresse dit que 33% des 60-63 ans en
France sont en emploi bien sûr et c'est
normal parce que en France on part à la
retraite bien plus tôt que dans les
autres pays de l'Europe et il est
souvent mauvais de prendre exemple les
autres pays de l'Europe on a pour
exemple la Suède qui voilà donc du coup
ce que je souhaite dire c'est que les
seniors pour une entreprise c'est une
richesse c'est c'est la mémoire de
l'entreprise et les seniors ont un
savoir-faire bien sûr qu'ils peuvent
transmettre voilà et je j'aimerais aussi
qu'il soit impossible dans la mesure du
possible que nos seniors
en emploi ne puisse pas être mis à la
porte si le métier est en tension donc
si on trouve pas un remplaçant voilà et
je voudrais aussi
mettre en avant la formation et des
seniors et leur reconversion et
vraisemblablement la mise en poste doux
pour ces personnes qui
avançant dans l'âge
sont un peu moins efficients voilà et je
voudrais aussi qu'on qu'on
redéfinisse ce qu'est un senior parce
que je commence à me faire du souci
est-ce que vous pensez que je dois aller
à la SNCF prendre ma carte senior voilà
j'ai 47 ans merci
très bien monsieur Daredevil
oui merci madame la Présidente
sur ce sujet je partage les objections
qui ont été émises par Charlotte
Parmentier Lecoq il y a quelques
instants
la cotisation
ATMP elle est moduler selon des critères
qui sont aujourd'hui liés effectivement
à la sinistralité aux maladies
professionnelles aux accidents du
travail qui qui surviennent dans une
dans une entreprise et donc elles ont
aussi une vertu
incitative préventive qui d'ailleurs
mériterait d'être renforcé je le dis
parce que la modulation est trop faible
et là c'est pas simplement moi qui le
dit c'est la Cour des comptes
qui chaque année le dit voilà c'est ça
fait l'objet d'un d'un rapport de ma
part il y a quelques années de ça dans
la précédente législature et la Cour des
comptes à elle-même ensuite émis un avis
en ce sens je pense d'ailleurs que
certains collègues avaient peut-être
émis l'idée qu'on pourrait évoluer
là-dessus
et je voilà je pense qu'il y a des
sujets à ouvrir sur sur la question de
la cotisation ATMP il y a des sujets à
ouvrir aussi sur peut-être les outils
supplémentaires dont il faudrait se
doter en matière de santé au travail et
peut-être le rôle que pourrait jouer les
CARSAT en la matière donc là il y a il y
a des chantiers importants mais le lien
que vous effectuez dans l'amendement me
semble assez douteux bizarre en réalité
et je crains que ça que ça n'est pas
véritablement les effets positifs que
vous en attendez
d'autant que pardon madame la Présidente
j'ajoute mais ça ça sera un débat qu'on
aura sans doute plus tard la
sous-déclaration des maladies
professionnelles notamment et
singulièrement forte ce qui amène la
branche à TMP à financer de manière très
logique la branche maladie qui doit
supporter cette sous-décration je pense
d'ailleurs que même cette sous
déclaration elle est sous-évaluée donc
là on voit bien qu'il y a un certain
nombre de sujets qui sont ouverts par
cet amendement et qui ne traite
absolument pas d'ailleurs c'est pas son
objet mais je crois il faut être très
très attentif à ce que déjà la branche
ATMP puisse assumer ses missions
correctement
très bien monsieur gerdigon
oui merci madame la Présidente je
j'appuie et je reviens sur ce qui a été
dit par mes collègues notamment
Charlotte Parmentier le coq sur bien sûr
les compétences
l'expertise comment dire des seigneurs
qu'il faut absolument transmettre je
pense personnellement il y a vraiment un
statut un statut du salarié senior a
créé il y a eu quelques exemples qui ont
été donnés sur par exemple les personnes
qui interviennent à domicile c'est une
personne âgée c'est vrai que d'être tout
seul à porter à bouger une personne âgée
c'est compliqué mais il y a aussi des
personnes qui ont cette expérience qui
l'ont fait depuis des années et qui
pourraient être présente justement à
côté des plus jeunes pour donner des
conseils et apporter leur savoir-faire
donc je pense qu'il y a tout toute une
réflexion moi je pense aussi voilà j'ai
un frère qui est routier il a commencé à
travailler à 15 ans dans la mécanique
après il a choisi le métier des routiers
il a fait de l'international il a arrêté
à 59 ans et aujourd'hui et bien il
apporte son savoir-faire sur la façon de
conduite pour pour faire des économies
d'énergie et chose comme ça je pense que
dans tous les métiers il y a vraiment
quelque chose à penser alors moi
j'espère personnellement dans la dans la
future loi sur le plein emploi on va
aborder vraiment ce travail des seniors
et d'apporter un peut être un statut
branche par branche activité par
activité sur ces personnes qui méritent
encore de travailler et qui ont encore
envie de travailler
très bien monsieur Vigier
oui merci madame la Présidente chacun a
bien compris qu'au traversait deux
amendements on essayait d'apporter cette
réponse
à laquelle nous aspirons tous concernant
l'emploi des seniors et d'ailleurs je
renvoie chacune et chacun d'entre vous
elle a très belle lecture du rapport de
Jean-René Lorenzi luciaire des
économistes qui je crois est assez
éclairont ces deux amendements le
premier c'était donc pour baisser des
taux d'accident travail et maladie
professionnelles madame la rapporteur
fait paniquement de modulation c'était
baissé parce que c'est un frein après
avoir auditionné les partenaires sociaux
on a vu combien c'était un frein il faut
l'entendre comme cela donc c'est pas
uniquement on n'a pas ébauché madame
Parmentier le coq comme ça sans regarder
on est allés au fond des choses et
lorsqu'on propose une modulation ou par
exemple des bonus malus je vous rappelle
pour les bonus malus chers collègues que
dans les CDD n'est-ce pas non mais comme
vous avez tout à l'heure ça a été à
peine débauché donc je vous réponds nous
avons beaucoup travaillé sur ce sujet là
et sur les bonus phallus dans les CDD
c'est quelque chose qui a très bien
marché et que à laquelle personne ne
croyez au début la preuve et Marc
ferrachi pourrait le dire ce qu'il y a
pas longtemps je vous rappelle que dans
la réforme d'assurance chômage mais
comme je me permets de vous répondre
c'est normal c'est d'éval démocratique
et donc sur cette affaire du bonus malus
ça a permis justement de montrer toute
la pertinence de voir que ces CDD moins
étonnants et naturellement moins la
pénalisation est toute au rendez-vous et
puis ils étaient nombreux puis la
pénalisation est toujours au rendez-vous
donc on essaye modestement de trouver un
chemin ce chemin imaginez pas qu'on l'a
trouvé comme ça aux éditions d'une table
écrit un moment ou un autre seulement on
a essayé de le voir comment pouvait le
construire dans les invites chacune et
chacun d'entre vous à réfléchir à ces
deux pistes qu'il y avait beaucoup
d'humilité devraient participer me
semble-t-il à faire en sorte que nous
soyons pas les bras ballants en se
disant on a 33% de seniors qui
travaillent avec 45 milliards d'euros de
cotisations qui rentrent pas dans les
caisses donc je crois que si c'est un
facteur d'équilibre des finances
publiques
très bien Madame la rapporteur vous
souhaitiez dire un mot oui merci
j'entends bien chers collègues et je dis
juste que sur le fait de moduler sur
cette branche à TMP va entraîner que
certaines entreprises par exemple avec
beaucoup d'accent de travail qui
emploient par exemple beaucoup de
seniors vont voir leur diminution de
leur cotisation de la branche ATMP et
donc ça me paraît un effet de bord par
exemple sur votre amendement d'autre
part pour les CDD vous en parler c'est
effectivement des modulations de
cotisation sur la branche assurance
chômage sur l'assurance chômage pardon
qui relève d'un décret de 2019 donc il
me semble que l'écriture en modulant sur
cette branche ATMP et pas la bonne façon
de ce que vous voulez proposer derrière
très bien Madame kéké je suis désolé
mais il y a quelqu'un qui s'est déjà
exprimé pour votre groupe
[Musique]
merci à vous très bien Madame la
rapporteur oui juste effectivement
j'avais bien vu que c'était pas les deux
même mais dans le celui dont
l'amendement dont vous parlez le 71 90
vous parlez de minoration de majoration
de cotisations sociales des employeurs
et pas de cotisation salariale donc ça
comprend aussi éventuellement des
cotisations de la branche ATMP très bien
donc sur ce je vais mettre au voie donc
c'est amendements l'un après l'autre qui
ont tous les deux reçus un avis
défavorable de Madame la rapporteur
général donc je mets au voile 71 89 qui
est pour et on lève bien la main que je
puisse compter
qui est contre il est rejeté et je mets
aux voix l'amendement 71 90 qui est pour
on reste concentré qui est contre il est
rejeté je vous remercie mes chers
collègues amendement identique madame
Corneloup vous avez la parole merci
madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur mes chers collègues le
présente amendement visa supprimé les
alias les alias 9 à 11 qui ont pour but
de sanctionner les entreprises mais
connaissant l'obligation de publication
prévue à l'article
l517 les entreprises dans le contexte
actuel n'ont pas besoin qu'on rajoute
une difficulté à celle déjà présente le
recours à la méthode punitive bien que
la sanction soit limitée à 1% de la
masse salariale n'est pas propice au
contexte et au développement de nos
entreprises nous devons être en capacité
d'accompagner nos entreprises et de
trouver des moyens innovants autre que
la sanction pour améliorer le taux
d'emploi des 55 64 ans cela a été dit et
je le partage les seniors sont une
richesse pour les entreprises c'est une
expérience c'est un savoir-faire c'est
un savoir être précieux il faut faire en
sorte que ces personnes qui ont envie de
travailler puissent travailler et mettre
les entreprises dans des conditions
favorables pour les embaucher je vous
remercie très bien Madame la rapporteur
votre avis sur cet amendement et
favorable très bien je mets aux voix
c'est pardon ah j'ai madame Bora
sur l'amendement de Madame non juste
très très rapidement moi je voudrais
vous donner des chiffres puisque des
chiffres qui viennent de la DARES de
l'Insee je pense qu'on peut en faire
froid
sur le chômage j'ai entendu dire qu'il y
avait de nombreux seniors au chômage
ces statistiques montrent que 2,1 des
seniors sont au chômage que 50% sont
retraités que 28% sont en emploi que
quatre et demi pour cent sont en emploi
retraite et 15% sont inactifs je soumets
ces chiffres à votre réflexion très bien
Madame madame
ibora madame kéké vous avez la parole
merci madame la Présidente je cours tout
à l'heure de la part de macronistes de
la droite des propos complètement graves
c'est qui qui me presque qui
je pense que c'est vous c'est ça la
réalité c'est vous qui méprisez le
peuple avec des mesures vides c'est vous
qui méprisez les seigneurs les femmes
les handicapés
nous nous demandons seulement des choses
réelles contre contrairement à vous nous
allons sur le terrain et je viens de là
je suis la preuve vivante
[Musique]
vous n'avez jamais fait le ménage non
vous avez déjà fait 40 litres vous savez
ce qu'on appelle dresser un lit vous
avez déjà poussé un chariot non non vous
n'avez jamais fait c'est pour ça que
vous méprisez les gens comme ça que vous
méprisez les gens vous n'avez jamais
dressé un lien vous n'avez jamais fait
40 chambres vous n'avez jamais travaillé
dans un hôtel ni dans un bâtiment ni
d'être agent de sécurité c'est pour ça
que vous méprisez les gens madame
ne méprise personne
parce que depuis tout à l'heure
voilà nous nous demandons la protection
des salariés surtout les seniors et les
femmes très bien
pourquoi vous me couper
voilà on vient de là on vous parle je
viens de là sur la preuve vivante donc
quand nous parlons il faut écouter ce
qu'on dit tu as déjà fait 40 litres qui
est déjà allé dans un dans un hôtel
c'est bien tenu de travail pour un
chariot personne
personne envoie-moi vos CV je vais voir
alors envoyez-moi vos CV on avait des
voitures oui c'est ça comme habitez-vous
refusez tout pour protéger pour protéger
les ceux que les je sais pas les patrons
voilà les plus riches en fait c'est ça
votre politique et le peuple n'en veut
pas de votre politique le peuple n'en
veut pas de votre politique
très bien Madame kéké très bien Madame
kéké je dirais simplement personne ne
méprise personne madame kéké personne ne
méprise personne le peuple c'est nous la
République c'est nous toutes et tous
point barre
monsieur turquois
je voudrais merci Madame à présent je
voudrais dire un mot à notre collègue
qui nous a déjà interpellé sur ces
sujets là
et je non mais je conteste pas que vous
avez sûrement eu un rapport au travail
compliqué on a
je voudrais je voudrais finir
et je conteste pas le combat que vous
avez mené vous-même vous l'avez
explicite
mais quand on rentre dans cet
argumentaire là moi des fois j'entends
des propos sur les agriculteurs je suis
agriculteur je pense que vous n'avez
jamais été agriculteur de ce point de
vue là
s'il vous plaît
monsieur le député poursuivez madame
kéké s'il vous plaît je ne vous je ne
vous ai pas coupé madame kéké je ne vous
ai pas coupé non mais tout le monde sait
d'où il vient tout le monde pas que vous
monsieur
on a tous des vécu quand vous vivez dans
un territoire très rural quand on a une
sensibilité différente suivant les
sujets et je pense
et je pense
bon je demande une pause de 5 minutes
nous allons reprendre
[Musique]
place à la zénitude et donc
nous passons donc au vote des amandes de
l'amendement des amendements il y en a
qu'un oui qui a reçu donc un avis
défavorable qui est pour
qui est contre il est rejeté nous avons
deux amendements identiques madame
Corneloup
5514 oui le deuxième nom mais voilà
merci un président c'est amendement visa
remplacer les alinéas neufs et 11
destinées à sanctionner les entreprises
pour les remplacer par un alinéa qui
viserait à inciter l'embauche des
seniors en accompagnant les entreprises
par des allégements de charges
patronales l'allègement ne cherche
patronale liée aux salariés de la
tranche 55 64 permettrait de donner la
possibilité aux entreprises de profiter
de l'expérience des seniors sans pour
autant subir des charges trop
importantes cette mesure constitue est
donc une véritable incitation à
l'embauche des seniors qui permettrait
d'augmenter leur taux d'emploi sans
avoir recours à des sanctions inadaptées
au conjoncture actuelle nous savons
combien les mesures coercitives sont
contre-productives je vous remercie très
bien Madame la rapporteur votre avis
c'est un avis défavorable il me semble
important déjà de définir l'index et les
indicateurs et les critères et de voir
ensuite dans les négociations
conventionnelles
très bien monsieur Bazin
la question c'est qu'est-ce qui va être
le plus efficace pour améliorer le taux
d'emploi est-ce que c'est un index ou un
choc fiscal voilà moi je crois davantage
dans chaque fiscal que dans l'index
surtout que le choc fiscal il s'adresse
à tout le monde y compris les
entreprises de moins de 300 salariés ce
qui peut permettre d'avoir beaucoup de
chiffres ont circulé depuis ce matin
notamment sur le faible taux d'emploi
des seniors la réalité c'est comment on
fait en sorte que les seigneurs qui sont
dans l'emploi ont les maintiennent dans
l'emploi dans les meilleures conditions
qui possibles de manière à permettre
peut-être des retraites progressifs de
manière plus simplifiée il y a une
question qui se pose parce que la borne
HD = -2 ans c'est quand même compliqué
parce que ça voudrait dire 64 - 2 62 or
aujourd'hui à retrait de possessive est
possible à 60 donc il y a tout un
travail à faire forcément dans le
dialogue social mais il y a des pistes à
trouver là dessus le deuxième élément
c'est que sur cette accompagnement là il
va falloir sur la formation reconversion
tut programme mentorat trouver aussi un
dispositif qui permette peut-être de
d'aller vers d'autres métiers sur ceux
qui ne sont pas dans l'emploi et quand
même qui est une réalité pour un certain
nombre il y a ceux qui sont très
éloignés de l'âge légal comment on fait
en sorte de pouvoir les remettre dans
l'emploi et de l'autre côté comment on
fait en sorte que les employeurs soient
incités à embaucher ces personnes donc
il y a un sujet d'employabilité il y a
un sujet d'attractivité on voit bien
d'ailleurs sur le taux de maladie
professionnelle si jamais une maladie
professionnelle est révélée chez un
senior qui est arrivé alors que
peut-être que la maladie professionnelle
est due à des employeurs précédents ou
des métiers précédents il y a besoin
qu'on a juste ça aussi donc je pense que
c'est pas qu'une question fiscale c'est
pas qu'une question d'index c'est tout
un ensemble alors j'ai bien compris que
dans le PLFSS rectificatif on pouvait
pas mais est-ce qu'on pourrait avoir les
intentions du Gouvernement à ce sujet
parce que très clairement on ne réglera
pas le taux d'emploi des seniors et on
améliorera pas le taux d'emploi
uniquement avec cette index donc on a
besoin de l'ensemble des outils qui sont
envisagés pour améliorer la donne
monsieur Clouet
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente cet
amendement est assez étonnant me
semble-t-il bon outre des questions
rédactionnelles c'est à dire qu'en
français on dit cotisation patronale et
non pas charges mais je laisse de côté
ce point-là le fond même consiste à nous
dire que au nom de l'accès à l'emploi
des seniors on va retirer des ressources
à la Caisse nationale de l'assurance
vieillesse par le biais des diminutions
de cotisations et c'est quand même assez
paradoxal d'être réuni ici parce que le
gouvernement nous dit il manque des
milliards et de ce et d'en arriver à la
conclusion que une des solutions serait
de retirer d'autres milliards peut-être
de la Caisse nationale d'assurance
vieillesse donc nous ne croyons
absolument pas à cette solution a
fortiori appliqué aux salariés de 55 ans
ou plus qui ont des salaires 50% plus
élevés que les jeunes en moyenne et donc
son plus gros contributeur en terme de
cotisations à la CNAV donc c'est une
forme de double privation de ressources
pour l'assurance vieillesse or
évidemment les salaires supérieurs à 366
euros dont je ne doute pas que vous nous
soutiendrez lorsque nous essayons d'élar
de la cotisation des plafonnés à ce
niveau là donc si les seniors ont un
prix c'est parce que la valeur à un prix
en tant que tel et se pose la question
du coup de comment favoriser leur accès
à l'emploi pour celles et ceux qui le
souhaitent puisque à nouveau le droit de
partir à la retraite n'est pas
l'obligation de liquider sa pension et à
notre sens mieux vaut empêcher les
licenciements mieux vaut dissuader par
le biais de surcotisation les
entreprises établissements de se séparer
des salariés d'un certain âge et
accompagner les sites vers
l'amélioration l'augmentation de la
productivité qui passe essentiellement
par la sécurisation des parcours des
personnes et la sécurisation dans
l'emploi pour limiter les accidents du
travail qui à cet âge
occasionne des incapacités beaucoup plus
régulières que chez les salariés jeunes
très bien monsieur Guedj
je voulais à l'instar de mon collègue
cloué pointé l'importance de la bataille
des mots et quand nos collègues LR
veulent glisser au détour d'un
amendement un terme qui ne figure pas
dans le code de la sécurité sociale en
rebaptisant les cotisations patronales
qui participent du salaire différé en
charge patronales il s'inscrivent dans
leur
ADN et c'est tout à fait respectable
mais ce faisant ils insistent sur la
dimension pour ne pas dire l'obsession
de la baisse du coût du travail là où
depuis hier nous insistons en matière
d'emploi des seniors sur les mesures à
la fois d'incitation mais aussi
éventuellement de pénalisation vous
pouvez appeler ça coercition nous
revendiquons le terme qui s'incarne
précisément dans une de malus de
surcotisation qui s'appliquent dès
l'instant où l'effort et les mesures de
prévention pour maintenir l'emploi des
seniors non pas été prises alors juste
alors justement donc c'est la raison
pour laquelle on peut pas souscrire
évidemment ni à la philosophie ni aux
modalités de cette amendement
oui merci madame le Président simplement
je voulais réagir à nos collègues des
républicains puisque vous proposez
finalement un dispositif que nous avions
proposé dans le cadre de notre niche
parlementaire sur l'allègement justement
des cotisations patronales pour inciter
à l'emploi bon en l'occurrence nous une
proposez pas de discrimination sur le
critère d'âge mais il me semble que vous
aviez voté abstention en commission et
contre un hémicycle c'est assez
paradoxal par rapport à ce que vous
proposez à l'instant
très bien Madame Corneloup vous
souhaitiez intervenir oui juste pour
revenir sur effectivement le fait que
alléger les cotisations patronales j'ai
entendu leur rectificatif viserait à
diminuer les recettes en même temps si
on permet au plus grand nombre de
seniors de travailler en augmentant
aussi l'assiette et je crois que plus
que jamais et bien nous devons être dans
l'incitation à la fois pour permettre à
ceux qui sont en emploi d'y rester mais
également pour permettre à ceux qui sont
au chômage de retrouver un emploi et
nous devons plus que jamais accompagner
les entreprises et leur faire confiance
merci très bien Madame la rapporteur oui
merci je comprends le sens sauf que là
vous vous baissez des cotisations sur le
assiette très très large puisque c'est à
partir de 55 ans avec un index il n'est
pas encore défini des objectifs donc pas
d'études préalable de ciblage de ces
exonérations donc ça me paraît vraiment
très très large et beaucoup trop large
pour qu'on soit sûr d'une certaine
efficacité donc avis défavorable
très bien alors je mets aux voix donc
cet amendement qui a reçu un avis
défavorable qui est pour
qui contre il est rejeté amendement
pouvant être mis en discussion commune
monsieur Petavy
vous pouvez les défendre les trois
monsieur petavi non non je vais pas
prévu
je vous écoute nous vous écoutons bien
oui donc
le gouvernement souhaite miser sur
l'emploi des seniors très bien mais
arrêtons de miser sur la bonne volonté
des entreprises une politique des
seigneurs ne se résume pas un
questionnaire ou avoir un score
suffisant n'est qu'une option nous avons
à disposition le levier financier des
exonérations de cotisations aux
entreprises nous appelons donc à nous en
servir pour faire de cette index un réel
outil d'amélioration de l'emploi des
seniors merci
et bien Madame la madame la rapporteur
général
c'est bien ça donc amendement suivant
monsieur Petavy
pardon c'est c'est vous qui le défendez
non mais alors attendez moi je suis
perdu monsieur petavi vous pouvez
défendre l'amendement suivant
merci de rien
il est maintenant plutôt clair pour tout
le monde que non seulement c'est index
senior est une pâle copie de l'index
d'égalité professionnelle mais c'est une
copie au rabaisse alors que l'index
d'égalité prévoyait au moins
l'obligation d'atteindre le seuil de
résultats nous pensons donc qu'il y a
en maintenant relatif consensus sur la
nécessité de cet index que cette index
ne se réduise pas la simple obligation
de publication qu'il ne sera qu'un
simple questionnaire est une formalité
s'il n'y a aucune obligation à avoir des
résultats satisfaisants nous espérons
donc
qu'au-delà du montant des sanctions bien
qu'elles soient d'un montant ridicule
actuellement nous puissions nous
accorder sur la nécessité que cet index
oblige les entreprises à atteindre un
score minimum nous sommes tous et toutes
d'accord sur l'inutilité du dispositif
en l'état actuel soyons donc au moins
d'accord pour qu'il soit conditionné à
minima à l'obtention d'une note
suffisamment élevée très bien maintenant
suivant monsieur Peytavi
alors j'ai maintenant l'occasion de
défendre à nouveau un amendement allant
dans le sens de renforcement des
sanctions à l'encontre des entreprises
qui ont un score insuffisant et à cet
égard je rappelle aux député du
rassemblement national qui s'auto
programmée hier grande défenseur des
petits patrons mais apparemment pas des
femmes mais c'est justement parce que
nous pensons qu'une entreprise selon sa
taille n'a pas la même capacité
poursuivez monsieur Petavy poursuivez
monsieur
différenciées et pondérés à la taille de
l'entreprise leur rassemblement national
ne s'est contenté que d'une cinquantaine
d'amendements de surface c'est à croire
que vous aviez cours d'Aqua poney quand
il fallait travailler sur cette loi ce
qui n'est pas sérieux c'est que vous ne
proposez aucune alternative crédible et
de fait vous envoyer le signal à la
majorité que vous êtes bel et bien sa
route secours nous au groupe écologistes
nous sommes force de proposition et nous
nous battons pour que les seniors aussi
bien les femmes que les hommes soit
reconnu alors juste valeur dans les
entreprises et de fait c'est pour cela
que nous proposons un délai adapté aux
entreprises pour répondre à l'index
allant d'un an pour les entreprises de
moins de 250 personnes à huit mois pour
les entreprises de taille intermédiaire
et oui contrairement au rassemblement
national nous partons aussi du principe
que les multinationales sont redevables
et doivent être responsabilisés et
sanctionnés lourdement en cas de
licenciement massif de seniors
très bien la parole est à Monsieur Monet
ou monsieur d'arriville oui merci madame
la Présidente donc cet amendement
effectivement vise lui aussi a
sanctionner d'une part la non
publication des indicateurs de l'index
senior mais aussi à sanctionner des
entreprises dans les indicateurs
démontreraient que l'objectif
d'amélioration des conditions d'emplois
et d'embauche des salariés âgés de 50
ans et plus ne serait pas atteint
c'est-à-dire qu'il s'agit de donner une
forme d'efficacité d'effectivité à ce
dispositif et de ne pas se contenter
d'une simple publication mais
véritablement de l'accompagner nous
l'avions déjà proposé d'objectifs et
d'objectifs dont
on contrôle le fait que ils ont été
respectés en tout cas qu'ils ont été
suivis d'action pour pouvoir les honorer
voilà donc l'idée c'est d'essayer quand
même d'avoir un dispositif qui qui soit
un peu plus puissant que celui qui nous
est proposé puisque celui qui nous est
proposé en réalité n'a aucun effet
madame la Présidente je crois que ces
amendements ils font écho de nombreuses
autres que nous avions déposé pendant le
PLFSS ou effectivement on s'inscrivait
dans une logique où il y a pas
finalement de cadeaux gratuits aux
entreprises et on conditionne en effet
les exonérations
moi j'ai participé à une table ronde
avec le HCE et il y avait notre collègue
Marie-Pierre rexin et notamment il y
avait des chefs d'entreprise ou des
cadres d'entreprise et j'entends
beaucoup ici qu'on devrait pas
contraindre les entreprises qu'il faut
leur faire confiance etc mais là par
exemple on avait un cadre de L'Oréal qui
disait lui-même que ils ont progressé
sur les questions d'égalité parce qu'il
y avait des contraintes alors
aujourd'hui on dit que les contraintes
elles sont pas suffisantes mais les
entreprises elles-mêmes mettaient en
avant que c'est parce qu'il y avait de
la contrainte alors au début il l'admet
de volontiers que au début c'était
simplement un peu entraînant des pieds
pour la cosmétique etc pour le
maquillage mais que après à terme
finalement ça a créé des vrais
dynamiques et aujourd'hui ils sont pour
la plupart assez fiers du chemin qui
sont parcourus même si tout n'est pas
parfait qui a encore beaucoup de mesures
à mettre en place donc je crois que s'il
y a un saignement à tirer c'est que
finalement les entreprises même si elles
vont traîner les pieds et oui c'est
difficile au début parce que le
changement est difficile au début à
terme la contrainte nous sert
collectivement
très bien monsieur Coulomme
oui je voudrais interpeller à nouveau
les les supporters de cette réforme dans
sa globalité
en montrant qu'il y a quand même une
drôle d'hypocrisie finalement à vouloir
établir des index qui sont censés
apporter une protection à un certain
nombre de catégories professionnelles
essentiellement les seniors les femmes
les handicapés les travailleurs
précaires les travailleurs ont du malade
par un une activité accidentogène ou
psychologiquement déstructurantes des
carrières longues celles des apprentis
notamment enfin finalement on a là
l'impression que on a envie de de
d'alléger en quelque sorte les
souffrances et la violence de cette loi
que vous promouvez
avec des index qui permettent de
visualiser que on prend soin de toutes
ces catégories là en réalité c'est
justement ces index là avec le les
catégories qui sont visées par ces index
que nous pouvons préjugés de qui va
faire les frais de cette réforme de
cette contre-réforme des retraites parce
qu'en réalité celles et ceux qui ont
écrit ce texte finalement ont commencé à
travailler tard parce qu'ils ont fait
des études longues ils ont des métiers
qui ne sont pas dans les mêmes
situations de souffrance au travail pour
certains c'est même des métiers passions
je ne sais pas avocats chirurgiens
directeur commercial etc on médecin etc
donc finalement cette oui député les
filles si vous voulez oui exactement
mais appliquons-nous à nous-mêmes
appliquons-nous à nous-mêmes chers
collègues finalement la rigueur de cette
contre-réforme
donc vous voyez bien que là ici on a des
index qui servent de de bonnes
conscience à l'esprit délétère de cette
contre-réforme et ça nous montre bien
que c'est vers ces catégories là que les
efforts vont être
imposés et non pas à ceux qui ont écrit
cette loi très bien monsieur Mounet
merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues en 91 1991 le Conseil d'État
constaté déjà quand la loi bavarde le
citoyen lui prêtent une oreille
distraite et je crains que nous
bavardions sur ces amendements et avec
tout le respect que je vous dois que je
n'arrive même pas à lire est-ce que ça
c'est vraiment dans le domaine de la loi
on a un constat que nous essayons de de
d'appréhender d'avoir un taux d'emploi
des seniors de 56% des 55 64 ans qui est
même 33% entre les 60 et 63 qui est très
insatisfaisant au regard de la moyenne
européenne au regard des meilleurs
élèves européens comme la Suède l'index
qui est proposé va jouer un rôle
d'incitation avec une obligation de
publication mais le résultat attendu
dépendra des entreprises ça nous sommes
d'accord là-dessus faisons confiance au
dialogue social faisons confiance au
dialogue de branche et peut-être le
moment venu évaluons
le dispositif mais venir à ce stade
contraindre de manière aussi fine les
les choses dans le texte de loi je
crains que l'on soit là contre-productif
et on est bien loin de portaliser merci
à vous
moi je
vais aller dans le sens de ces
amendements qui correspondent à la
volonté ministérielle
puisque oui si on lit bien le
compte-rendu du conseil des ministres du
23 janvier le gouvernement voulait des
sanctions le gouvernement voulait
renforcer finalement le caractère
coercitif de cet index qui si il n'est
pas complété par un de sanction n'a
aucun effet donc là ce qu'on vous
propose ici c'est simplement de donner
une forme d'effectivité à ce qui sinon
ne sera qu'un écran de fumée un élément
de langage de la majorité destiné à
faire semblant d'avoir accompagné
l'amélioration de l'emploi des seniors
sans sanction pas d'effectivité c'est la
base nous sommes ici à l'Assemblée
nationale quand on fait une loi on met
des sanctions pour ceux qui ne la
respecte pas et d'ailleurs même les
ministres le reconnaissent donc s'il
vous plaît aidez-nous à appuyer le
gouvernement en ce sens
très bien donc je mets aux voix ces
amendements qui ont reçu tous un avis
négatif
le 3815 qui est pour
qui est contre il est rejeté même à vie
même vote sur le 37 94
oui pardon oui
mais ma vie même vote pour le oui non
mais on conteste pas s'il vous plaît je
non mais ma vie même vote pour le 37 91
voilà même avis même vote pour le 31 53
oui donc ils sont tous rejetés je vous
souhaite un excellent à petit on se
retrouve après les QG merci